ओके सो वी आर
लाइव ठीक है हेलो एवरीबॉडी
राधे राधे राम राम लव फ्रॉम गुजरात लव
फ्रॉम इंडिया
ब्रदर सभी लोग आवाज सुन पा रहे हैं मेरी
क्लियर क्रिस्टल क्लियर ऑडियो वीडियो सब
कुछ है बता दीजिए मुझे एक बार कंफर्म कर
दीजिए प्लीज प्लीज कंफर्म प्ली
कंफर्म हेलो पंकज हेलो
दीपक सो मुझे एक बार कंफर्म कर दीजिए
ऑडियो वीडियो सब एकदम झकास बढ़िया
ना हां जी हां जी हां जी हेलो हेलो हेलो
क्लियर है चलिए बढ़िया बढ़िया बहुत बढ़िया
तो आज जाने देते हैं सभी लोगों को पहले
पहले तो 100 लोगों को जवाइन करने देते
हैं
क्योंकि य लाइव सेशन है एंड मैंने आपको
बोला ही था कि 100 अटें चाहिए कंटिन्यू
करने के लिए हमारे सीरीज को सो लेट एवरी
बडी
जॉइन वीडियो इज नॉट प्रॉपर वीडियो की में
क्या दिक्कत है भाई वीडियो भी तो प्रॉपर
है वीडियो भी तो प्रॉपर है मैं बढ़िया हूं
यार
बढ़िया
हेलो हेलो एवरी बडी हेलो
ओके सर सुबह से वेट कर रहा था सेशन का
चलिए बहुत बढ़िया अच्छी बात है सुबह से आप
वेट कर रहे थे इतना वेट करते हो यार ट्स
ग्रेट आ जाने देते हैं
सो वी हैव 34 करेंटली 35 पीपल लाइव र आज
पता है ना क्या करने वाले हम होस्ट हेडर
में ही आगे का जो हमारा बचा हुआ था पार्ट
पोर्शन जो कि हम प्रीवियस सेशन में नहीं
कर पाए थे उसको कवर करने वाले हैं उसको हम
कंप्लीट करने वाले हैं बहुत ही
इंटरेस्टिंग चीज है जिसके अंदर में वेब
कैश पॉइजनिंग आएगी जिसके अंदर
में पासवर्ड रिसेट पॉइजनिंग आएगी जिसके
अंदर में आपका एक्सेसेस थ्रू होस्ट ड
इंजेक्शन आएगा यह सब आएगा बट पहले आ जाने
देते सबको गुड वीडियो ऑडियो बहुत बढ़िया
अच्छी बात है हाउ आर यू डूइंग आई एम गुड
विजेंदर
हा हेलो आरसी टेक हेलो साइबर टेक
निखिल कितना और पेंडिंग है अभी तो बहुत
पेंडिंग है अभी तो यार चलेगा यार यह लंबा
चलेगा मैंने बोला ही था लंबा चलेगा आपको
पहले ही बोला था लंबा
चलेगा ल ल लंबा चलेगा अभी
तो
नो एक्शन
टोटल 60 मोर
नीडेड 6 लोग और आएंगे तब हम शुरू करेंगे
क्योंकि उसके पहले तो नहीं
करेंगे देखते हैं लेट्स
वेट हेलो बॉस सर जी शाउट आउट दे दो आरसी
टेक बोल दिया भाई कितना और पेंडिंग है
बहुत सारा पेंडिंग है भाई बहुत
सारा सर आपको दिल से थैंक यू बोलना चाहता
हूं सच्ची आपके थ्रू बहुत कुछ सीखने को
मिला
है ओके बहुत बढ़िया
भाई
वेलकम सर वीडियो थोड़ा फास्ट फास्ट लो
वीडियो फास्ट कैसा होता है मतलब समझा नहीं
मैं हैकर किस टाइप से फास्ट बोल रहे हो
जरा व
बताओ हाय ड्यूड हेलो अरविंद हाय स हाउ आर
यू आईम
गुड ऐसा होना चाहिए को की पेट देने वाले
रो पड़े वैसा ही कोस है भाई रो ही रहे हैं
सब
लोग स्टार्ट द क्लास सॉरी ब्रदर क्लास तभी
स्टार्ट होगी जब 100 लोग यहां पर हो
जाएंगे पहले ही मैंने बो बोल दिया है
थोड़ा आप लोग भी सीरियस हो जाइए जब मैं
सीरियस हूं इतना तो आप लोग भी सीरियस होइए
ताकि मजा है सेशन कराने में ठीक है चलो 50
लोग 53 लोग हो चुके हैं बहुत बढ़िया 53
लोग आ चुके हैं यहां पर और भी आ जाने देते
सबको
जवाइन करने देते
सबको सीरीज थोड़ी फास्ट लो ज्यादा फास्ट
नहीं कर सकते बहुत लोग पीछे रह रहे हैं तो
इसलिए वह नहीं कर
सकते ऐसा करो कि इंडिया के बाहर वाली भी
कोर्स खरीद सके जो देखो इंडिया के बाहर
वाले भी खरीद सकते हैं बिल्कुल भी अगर
आपके पास इंटरनेशनल डेबिट या क्रेडिट
कार्ड है तो आप यूज कर सकते हो कोई दिक्कत
नहीं गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग
मुझे एक बार सब सच सच ईमानदारी से दिल से
बता दो आप लोगों का कितने क्लास तक किसका
किसका कंप्लीट हुआ है आप लोगों में से
किसका किसका कितने क्लास तक कंप्लीट हुआ
है चैट में लिख दो जरा सभी लोग लिख देना
एकदम ईमानदारी ऑनेस्टली बताना गड़बड़ सरब
मत मत करना
प्लीज बता दो जल्दी
फटाफट
देखते
हैं एड पन टेस्टिंग का कोर्स बहुत जल्द
आने वाला
है जल्दी बताओ चैट
में 14 26 ऑल कंप्लीटेड सेन सारी हो गई 26
ल
कंप्लीटेड ठीक है 187 26 25 18 इवनिंग
एवरीथिंग ऑल ठीक
है
ओके ओके अश फुल थैंक
यू चलिए तो
गाइस चलिए तो आज
आप लोग आप लोग शायद सीरियसली नहीं ले पा
रहे मेरी बात को या सीरियसली आप लोग नहीं
ले रहे हैं मेरे मेरे जो भी मैं बोल रहा
हूं कि 100 अटें हमें चाहिए कैसे भी करके
बट नहीं ले रहे हैं तो कोई कोई मतलब नहीं
अ
अ सर मेरा एग्जाम चल रहा है इसलिए कुछ दिन
से लाइव नहीं है कोई बात नहीं हाउ इज योर
हेल्थ टुडे सर आई एम गुड रबन आई एम गुड
टुडे चलिए तो आज का टॉपिक स्टार्ट करते
हैं आज का जो टॉपिक है होस्ट हेडर का ही
पार्ट टू है ये ठीक है ना तो होस्ट
हेडर
इंजेक्शन पार्ट टू है
यह पार्ट टू है तो लास्ट पार्ट में हमने
लास्ट पार्ट में हमने ओपन रीडायरेक्शन को
बहुत डिटेल में पढ़ा था होस्ट हेडर के
थ्रू आज जो है हम आज हम करने वाले हैं वेब
कैश पॉइजनिंग
एंड
पासवर्ड
रिसेट पॉइजनिंग
एंड एक्सेसेस
थ्रू होस्ट
हेडर होस्ट हेडर ठीक है तीन चीजें हम
मेनली इसमें करने वाले हैं बहुत ही
इंपॉर्टेंट है यह तीनों के तीनों इन तीनों
में जो भी वने एबिलिटीज अगर आपको मिलती है
किसी वेब एप्लीकेशन के अंदर तो आपको 100%
रिवॉर्ड मिलेगा यानी कि बाउंट मिलेगी
पेआउट मिलेगा जो भी जैसा प्रोग्राम जैसा
उनका जो भी पॉलिसी है उसके अकॉर्डिंग आपको
रिवॉर्ड मिलेगी ठीक है तो तो यह बहुत
इंपॉर्टेंट है इसको आप एकदम से ध्यान
दीजिएगा बिल्कुल ध्यान दीजिएगा अगर आप
इसको ध्यान नहीं देंगे तो तो फिर आपका
बहुत कुछ रह जाएगा मेरे ख्याल से ठीक है
बहुत कुछ आपका रह जाएगा बहुत कुछ आपको
लाइक ये वनबिल आपको कवर करनी करनी है इसके
बिना आपको आगे नहीं बढ़ना है जरूर से जरूर
कवर करना है तो सबसे पहले हम स्टार्ट जो
करेंगे वेब कैश पॉइजनिंग से करेंगे वेब
कैश पॉइजनिंग ठीक है अब देखो वेब कैश
पॉइजनिंग को स्टार्ट करने से पहले इसको
समझना जरूरी है किसको समझना जरूरी है वेब
कैश को समझना जरूरी है कि भैया वेब कैश
क्या होता है चलिए इसको समझते हैं पहले तो
वेब
कैश फिर हम इसको पॉइजन करेंगे मतलब इसको
हम मलेशियन तरीके से मलेशियन अप्रोच से हम
अटैक करेंगे इसका यूज करके और जो भी
यूजर्स है जो जेनरिक यूजर्स है उनको कैस्ट
पॉइजन कैस्ट जो पेज है सर्व करेंगे एंड
वहां से हम उनकी बैंड बजाएंगे ठीक है
सिंपल सा फंडा यही हैकर्स बेसिकली यही कर
रहे हैं तो वेब कैश का मतलब क्या हो जाता
है वेब कैश का अ रियल एक्चुअली क्या मतलब
होता है इसको हम समझते हैं ठीक है तो मैं
यहां पोर्ट फिगर पे
हूं ऑल टॉपिक्स मैं करता हूं यहां पे अ
नीचे चलते हैं हम यहां
पे एंड कुछ एडवांस टॉपिक्स में आके
एटीटीपी होस्ट सेटर में चलते हैं यहां पे
आएंगे तो हमें वेब कैश पॉइजनिंग मिलेगी हम
इस पे चलते हैं तो यहां पे हमें लैब मिल
रहा है चलो कोई बात नहीं यहां पे अ वेब
कैश पॉइजनिंग के टॉपिक पे आ जाते हैं यहां
पे आते हैं ठीक है अब देखो यहां पे क्या
मतलब हो जाता है वेब कैश का मतलब क्या हो
जाता है टू अंडरस्टैंड हाउ वेब कैश पंग टी
अराइज इट इ इंपोर्टेंट टू है बेसिक हाउ
वेब कैश वर्क ठीक है तो सिंपल होता क्या
है पहले वह समझ देते हैं मान लो ऑनलाइन
वाइट बोर्ड पर चलते
हैं मैं ओपन कर लेता हूं मान लो यह है
क्लाइंट
अपना यह है अपना सर्वर क्या होता है जब
पहली बार कोई रिक्वेस्ट जाती है मान लो एक
क्लाइंट है ना मल्टीपल क्लाइंट्स होते हैं
मल्टीपल क्लाइंट्स होते हैं अब मान लो कि
हर रिक्वेस्ट का सर्वर को अगर रिप्लाई
करना होता इन रियल में अगर ऐसा होता बाय
चांस तो सर्वर के ऊपर कितना लोड
पड़ता हर रिक्वेस्ट के लिए क्योंकि अब एक
क्लाइंट नहीं है ना यह क्लाइंट भी भेजा
रिक्वेस्ट यह भी भेज रहा है यह भी भेज रहा
है यह भी भेज रहा है यह भी भेज रहा है और
सेम पेज के लिए भेज रहा है मान लो सेम पेज
ओके ऐसा नहीं है कि डिफरेंट डिफरेंट पेजेस
के लिए भेज रहा है ये सेम पेज के लिए भेज
रहा
है तो मैं करता हूं पेज का नाम दे देता
हूं
अ इक्सड
पीएपी ठीक है इस सेम पेज के लिए यह सारे
रिक्वेस्ट जा रहे हैं बस अब बात को इस चीज
को आप समझिए कि यहां पे हो क्या रहा
है अब जब इन सारे रिक्वेस्ट का सर्वर को
रिप्लाई करना पड़े सेम पेज के लिए सारे
क्लाइंट्स को सारे यूजर्स को तो ये बहुत
हेक्टिक हो जाएगा सर्वर के ऊपर काफी
ज्यादा लोड पड़ेगा इस चीज को सरकम वेंट
करने के लिए चीज से बचने के लिए कैशिंग
का कैशिंग का कांसेप्ट लाया गया अब यहां
पर कैश सर्वर होती है बीच में यहां पर एक
कैश सर्वर आप बोल सकते हैं बीच में एक
प्रेजेंट है अब पहली बार जब क्लाइंट सर्वर
को रिक्वेस्ट करता है तो सर्वर का जो
रिस्पांस होता है वह कैश हो जाता है
अकॉर्डिंग टू द डिपेंडिंग ऑन द कैश पॉलिसी
ठीक है वह कैश मेमोरी में चला जाता है अब
जब दोबारा यह क्लाइंट उसी सेम पेज को
रिक्वेस्ट करता है तो वह कैश मेमोरी से ही
क्लाइंट को मिल जाती है वापस ना कि सर्वर
के पास व रिक्वेस्ट जाती है सर्वर के पास
नहीं जाएगी व रिक्वेस्ट वह सीधा सीधा कहां
से कैश मेमोरी से ही क्लाइंट को मिल जाएगी
वापस से तो लोड कम हो गया सर्वर का टाइम
टेकिंग जो सर्वर तक रिक्वेस्ट जाती वो
मेमोरी से उसको मिल जा रही है ठीक है कैश
मेमोरी एक हो गया एंड वहां से उसको व चीज
मिल हर ब्राउजर का अपने कैश मेमोरी होता
है कैश स्टोरेज स एक लोकेशन होती है कैश
मेमोरी लोकेशन होती है तो उसी में वह सब
कुछ सेव करके रखता है तो समझ में आ रहा है
इतना समझ में यह कांसेप्ट समझ में आया
क्या होता है क्यों कैश की जरूरत पड़ी
क्यों यह इंपॉर्टेंट है सबको समझ में आया
यह बताइए
मुझे पहले मुझे बता दीज जल्दी
से ताकि मैं आगे
बढ यह समझ में आ
गया जल्दी जल्दी लेट मी फास्ट लेट मी नो
फास्ट ओके कैश की जरूरत है
ना जल्दी यार सभी लोग रिप्लाई नहीं करते
आप लोग आप लोग बहुत कम लोग रिप्लाई करते
हो यार तुम लोग क्या कर रहे हो भाई ऐसे
कैसे होने
का ऑफिस में रहता हूं लाइव लाइव नहीं जा
कोई बात नहीं लज ठीक
है ठीक है समझ में आ गया चलो ये तो क्लियर
हो गया
अब
यहां तो क्लियर हो गया तुम्हारा अब जस्ट
इमेजिन करो इमेजिन करो अगर कोई अटैकर किसी
मिस कन्फेशन की वजह से अगर कोई अटैकर इस
कैश जो पेज है कैश पेज उसको मेलिश पेलोड
से स्क्रिप्ट से इंजेक्ट कर दे
तो बाकी यूजर्स जिनको यह कैस्ट वर्जन पेज
का मिल रहा है उनको वो मशिन मिले पेज का
तो
अब यूजर ए क्लाइंट ए यूजर ए
ने रिक्वेस्ट करा था यह कैश वर्जन आ गई अब
यह कैश वर्जन में वेब कैश पॉइजनिंग करके
कोई अटैकर इसमें एक मेलिश स्क्रिप्ट या
मलेशियन पेलोड ऐड कर दे रहा है एंड बाकी
जो यूजर है बी सी डी इन सबको यही
मलेशियन वाली कैश वर्जन ऑफ पेज मिल रहा है
जिस पर वह क्लिक कर दे रहे हैं जा रहे
विजिट कर रहे हैं तो
उस केस में यहां पर हो जाती है वेब कैश
पॉइजनिंग समझ में आ रहा है यह वेब कैश
पॉइजनिंग है सिंपल सा फंडा है अब यह कैसे
होता है यह समझ लेते हैं द कैश सिट्स
बिटवीन द सर्वर एंड द यूजर सही है वेयर इट
सेव्स द रिस्पांसस टू पर्टिकुलर रिक्वेस्ट
यूजुअली फॉर अ फिक्स्ड अमाउंट ऑफ टाइम
कैशिंग का एक टाइम होता है एजिंग उसका एक
टाइम होता है एक एज होता है उस पर्टिकुलर
टाइम तक वो स्टोर करके रखता है इफ अनदर
यूजर सेंड्स एन इक्विवेलेंट रिक्वेस्ट द
सिम द कैश सिंपली सर्वस अ कॉपी ऑफ द कैस्ट
रिस्पांस डायरेक्टली टू द यूजर अगर सेम
इक्विवेलेंट रिक्वेस्ट भेजता है
इक्विवेलेंट रिक्वेस्ट जो कि कैश कीज के
मदद से कैलकुलेट की जाती है बात करेंगे
उसके ऊपर भी यह कांसेप्ट थोड़े समझने वाले
हैं अगर नहीं समझेंगे तो आपको मजा आपको
कभी नहीं समझ में आएगा वेब कैश पॉइजनिंग
बिल्कुल दिमाग से ऊपर चला जाएगा तो इसको
थोड़ा समझिए ध्यान एकदम यहीं पर दीजिएगा
ठीक है चलिए बग बाउंट ह ऐसे ही प्रो वाले
नहीं बन जाएंगे नॉर्मल बग बांटी हंटर कोई
भी बन जाएगा सी सी बात है सच बता रहा हूं
कोई भी हमारी बग बाउटी प्लेलिस्ट को फॉलो
कर लेगा ऊपर ऊपर का तो ऊपर ऊपर वाला हंटर
बन जाएगा लेकिन किसी को अंदर वाला हंटर
बनना है ना प्रो वाला खतरनाक वाला हंटर
बनना है ना बक बाउंट हंटर तो उसको हर एक
चीज एक एक माइन्यूट समझनी पड़ेगी तब जाके
बनेगा तभी तो दिमाग खुलेगा इफ अनदर यूजर
देन सेंड्स ठीक
है ओके द कैश सिंपली सव्स अ कॉपी ऑफ द कैश
रेस्पों डायरेक्टली टू द यूजर विदाउट एनी
इंटरेक्शन फ्रॉम द बैक एंड ओके दिस
ग्रेटली इज द लोड ऑन द सर्वर यह तो समझ
में आ गया अब बताइए अब आती है बात कैश कीज
की कैश कीज क्या होते हैं देखो व्हेन द
कैश रिसीव द एसटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट इट फर्स्ट
हैज टू डिटरमाइंड वेदर देयर इज अ कैश
रिस्पांस दैट इट कैन सर्व डायरेक्टली कोई
कैश रिस्पांस है कि नहीं कैश मेमोरी में
जिसको कि ये सर्व करेगा और वेदर इट हैज टू
फॉरवर्ड द रिक्वेस्ट टू द सर्वर अगर कैश
मेमोरी में नहीं है कैश कोई रिक्वेस्ट तो
उसको फिर से सर्वर को भेज देगा सिंपल सा
चीज है सर्वर को भेज देगा सर्वर फिर से
वापस से रिस्पांस करेगा फिर कैश मेमोरी
में सेव होगी फिर अगली रिक्वेस्ट से कैश
मेमोरी से जाएगी यह पूरा का पूरा साइकिल
चलता रहता है कैश
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
होते हैं ना वो इक्विवेलेंट रिक्वेस्ट को
कैसे कैसे मेजर करते हैं एक की के थ्रू
अगर वो कैश की मैच कर रही है हर रिक्वेस्ट
की यानी कि वो इक्विवेलेंट रिक्वेस्ट है
और उसको वह पेज विजिट करा दिया जाएगा वो
पेज कैस्ट पेज जो है चाहे वो पॉइजन कैस्ट
पेज क्यों ना हो उसको रिस्पांस में दे
दिया जाएगा मतलब जब भी रिक्वेस्ट आएगी
टिपिकली दिस शुड कंटेन द रिक्वेस्ट लाइन
एंड होस्ट हेडर सिंपल जो रिक्वेस्ट लाइन
होती है वो और जो होस्ट हेडर होता है वो
उन दोनों को ही मैच करते हैं जो रिक्वेस्ट
लाइन होती है यानी किस पेज को रिक्वेस्ट
कर रही है और होस्ट हेडर क्या है बस उसी
से कैश की डिफाइन हो जाता है यानी कि
होस्ट में क्या है google.com रिक्वेस्ट
स्ल को जारी उस पेज को
दैट्ची हमारा जनरेट हो गया हमें पता चल
गया यह कैश की कैलकुलेट हो गई इक्विवेलेंट
हर रिक्वेस्ट की कैश की इक्विवेलेंट अगर
होती है तो वो रिक्वेस्ट को सेम कैश पेज
सर्व किया जाता है ठीक है अब देखिए
कंपोनेंट्स ऑफ द रिक्वेस्ट दैट आर नॉट
इंक्लूडेड इन द कैश की आर सेड टू बी अन
कीड जो कंपोनेंट्स ऐसे कंपोनेंट्स जो कैश
की को कैलकुलेट करने में यूज नहीं आते
उसको अन कीड बोले जा बाकी ज सारे जो
हेडर्स है वो अन कीड हो जाते हैं
चलिए अब देखिए इफ द कैश की ऑफ एन इनकमिंग
रिक्वेस्ट मैसेज मैचेज द की ऑफ ए प्रीवियस
रिक्वेस्ट जिस रिक्वेस्ट की कैशिंग हुई थी
वो चाहे पॉइजन कैश हो या जेनुइन कैश
रिक्वेस्ट अगर वो कैश की मैच करता है
इनकमिंग रिक्वेस्ट का तो देन द कैश कंसीडर
देम टू बी इक्विवेलेंट एज अ रिजल्ट इट विल
सर्व अ कॉपी ऑफ द कैश रिस्पांस दैट वाज
जनरेट फ्रॉम द ओरिजिनल रिक्वेस्ट जो
ओरिजिनल रिक्वेस्ट से कैश जनरेट हुई थी
सिंपल सा इसका मतलब यही होता है बस देखिए
क्लाइंट ने एक रिक्वेस्ट भेजा पहला सवस
रिस्पांस आया कैश हो गया यह ओरिजिनल
रिक्वेस्ट हुई अब क्लाइंट दोबारा दोबारा
भेजता है रिक्वेस्ट बार-बार मल्टीपल
टाइम्स तो कैश की मैच होगी इक्विवेलेंट
रिक्वेस्ट होगी तो इसको कैश वाली पेज जो
है रिस्पांस के तौर पर इसको भेज दी जाएगी
कैश वाली रिस्पांस कैश पेज वाली सेम पेज
वाली भेज दी जाएगी दूसरे यूजर्स तीसरे
यूजर्स चौथे यूजर पांचवे यूजर्स जितने भी
यूजर्स ऐसे कर रहे हैं यहां पे ऐड आ गया
तो मैं इसको स्किप कर देता हूं जितने भी
यूजर्स इसको रिक्वेस्ट भेज रहे हैं अगर
सेम इक्विवेलेंट रिक्वेस्ट होगी तो उसको
सेम कै पेज यही सर्व की जाएगी सर्वर तक वो
रिक्वेस्ट नहीं जाएगी बस इतना तो आपको समझ
में आ गया होगा ठीक है ये बहुत ही बहुत ही
शानदार कांसेप्ट था ये वेब कैश पजनी को
समझने के लिए चलिए अब देखिए ये तो आप समझ
में आ गया अब अब अब ये समझिए अब ये समझिए
देखिए नीचे आ जाते हैं यहां पे
नीचे आ जाते य पे अब यहां पर क्या होगा कि
अब हम जब एक अटैकर पर्सपेक्टिव से देखेंगे
मान लो इस कैश मेमोरी को हम एक अटैकर
पर्सपेक्टिव से देख रहे ठीक है इसको मैं
चेंज कर देता हूं यहां
पे नाउ यर इ यर कम्स
अटैकर यहां पर एक अटैकर आता है अब हम
अटैकर पर्सपेक्टिव अगर जब देख रहे हैं तो
अगर अटैकर इस कैश को पॉइजन कर दे रहा
है पॉइजन कर दे रहा है तो इसको हम
वेब कैश पॉइजनिंग बोलते हैं वेब कैश
पॉइजनिंग इसको हम यही बोलते हैं वेब कैश
पॉइजनिंग सिंपल सा फंड
है उसको लिख सकते
हैं वेन एन
अटैकर
पॉइजन अ
कैश
वर्जन ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन
ऑफ ए
पेज एंड इट गेट सर्व टू
द इक्विवेलेंट
रिक्वेस्ट देन दिस इज नोन
एस
वेब
कैश पॉइजनिंग
ठीक है इसको हम क्या बोलते हैं वेब कैश
पॉइजनिंग
सिंपल सा फंड है न एन अटैकर पॉइजन अ कैश
वर्जन ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन या इंफॉर्मेशन लिख दो
ऑफ अ पेज एंड इट गेट सर्व टू द
इक्विवेलेंट रिक्वेस्ट देन दिस इज नोन एज
वेब कैश पॉइजनिंग बस सिंपल सा फंड है इसको
वेब कैश पॉइजनिंग बोलते हैं ठीक है इतना
समझ में आ रहा है
समझ में आ रहा है ये चीज कि समझ में आ रहा
है कि ऊपर से क्या भाई बताओ जरा
जल्दी थैंक यू एडिटिंग
एरा चलो बता दो ईमानदारी से सच्चाई से बता
दो समझ में
आया
ठीक है अंडरस्टूड ठीक है चलिए अच्छी बात
है अगर आप समझ गए तो वेरी गुड सो इफ यू
अंडरस्टूड वेरी गुड इसको हम वेब कैस्ट
पॉइज अब इसको ना थोड़ा प्रैक्टिकली भी
समझेंगे अब सिर्फ थियोरेटिकली समझ के तो
होगा नहीं है
ना ऊपर से जा रहा है अभी बट कोई बात नहीं
इसको रिपीट कीजिएगा अंदर से चला जाएगा
इसको जब आप रिपीट करेंगे आपको अंदर से चला
जाएगा इट्स माय गारंटी ठीक है बस सिंपल सा
कांसेप्ट है और कुछ भी नहीं है मतलब एक
कैश मेमोरी को भैया सिंपल सा कांसेप्ट है
यार एक कैश मेमोरी को पॉइजन कैश मेमोरी
बना देना है जिसमें कुछ मेलियस पेलोड या
स्क्रिप्ट होंगे और वही सारे यूजर्स को
दिए जाएंगे अब देखो जैसे क्या होता है यार
मैं तुमको सीधा-सीधा बताता हूं ठीक है एक
और बार बता देता हूं पहली अब जैसे देखो
मैं पहली बार डिफ क ओपन करूंगा तो यह मेरी
रिक्वेस्ट एक्चुअल सर्वर को गई है f.com
को एक्चुअल सब वर्क हो गई है अब मैं
दोबारा इस पेज को रीलोड करूंगा ना यह पेज
प्रीवियस जो हमारी रिक्वेस्ट थी उससे
ज्यादा फास्ट यह रिक्वेस्ट जाएगी ज्यादा
फास्ट यह पेज हमारे सामने आएगा एंड हमें
यह जल्दी पेज मिलेगा पहले से ज्यादा जल्दी
मिलेगा समझ में आ रहा है यह क्यों हुआ यह
कैशिंग के कारण हुआ दिस इज बिकॉज ऑफ द
कैशिंग क्योंकि दूसरी बार जब हमने इसको
रीलोड किया तो यह सर्वर के पास रिक्वेस्ट
नहीं गई ये कैश मेमोरी के पास गई
रिक्वेस्ट कैश मेमोरी में हमारा यह पेज
ऑलरेडी सेव्ड था तो सर्वर के पास
रिक्वेस्ट गई नहीं और वहां से यह पेज सर्व
होके आया मान लो कैश मेमोरी ही इफेक्टेड
हो
तो मान लो कैश मेमोरी ही इफेक्टेड हो तो
ये एक एग्जांपल की तरह एग्जांपल के तौर पर
आप बस समझ लीजिए आपने क्या किया यू वांट
टू टेक सम मिल्क फ्रॉम सम वेयर ठीक है
आपको मिल्क बाय करना है आप कहीं पे एक ऐसे
एक चले गए लाइक कोई एक होता है ना खटाल
किसी भी खटाल में चले गए जहां से आपको दूध
लेना है ठीक है भाई अब आप सोच रहे हो कि
यह खटाल इतनी बड़ी खटाल है यहां से इतने
इतने सारे अमाउंट में दूध यहां पे जनरेट
हो रहे हैं यहां कुछ ना कुछ कुछ मलेशियन
सकता है मलेशियन मिल्क मतलब हो सकता है
किसी में कोई कीड़ा हो मिल्क में कुछ ऐसा
हो तो एक मैं काम करूंगा व्हाट आई विल डू
मैं यह किसी एक छोटे से सेंटर से लूंगा अब
छोटे से सेंटर प आए और पता चले कि छोटा सा
सेंटर से आप मिल्क ले रहे हो बारबार जाके
वो टाल बहुत दूर है छोटा सेंटर आपके नजदीक
है अब मान लो छोटे से सेंटर को भी किसी ने
इफेक्ट कर दिया आगे चलके किसी ने गलती से
इफेक्ट कर दिया तो अब आपको छोटे से सेंटर
से भी जो दूध मिल रहा है जो बहुत नजदीक था
वो इफेक्टेड मिल्क मिल रहा है आपको सिंपल
सा चीज है वही सेम एग्जांपल यहां पे आपका
सेम चीज यहां पे आपका अप्लाई हो रहा है
ठीक है बस
दैट्ची एक्सएसएस का पेलोड है एक्सप्लोर
आवर कोर्सेस प ज जैसे ही क्लिक करूंगा
एक्सस का पेलोड ट्रिगर हो जाएगा पॉप अप आ
जाएगा एंड हमने एक्सस होस्ट स्टर से फाइंड
कर लिया सिंपल सा फंडा है वेब कैश
पॉइजनिंग के थ्रू बस यही तो चीज है ज्यादा
कुछ है ही नहीं चलिए अब इसको थोड़ा समझते
हैं प्रैक्टिकल अप्रोच में तो मैं क्या
करता हूं वेब कैश पॉइजनिंग प हूं मैं यहां
पे
हां
वे ऑल वेब कैश पॉइजनिंग
लैब्स स्टोर्ड एक्सेसेस लाइक अ नहीं लाइक
नहीं होता है आप एक्सेसेस फाइंड कर सकते
हो इसके थ्रू चलिए तो हम यहां पे वेब
कैस्ट पॉइजनिंग पे आ चुके हैं यहां पे ठीक
है वेब कस्ट पॉइजनिंग प यहां पे आ चुके
हैं ठीक है अब यहां पे हम क्या करते हैं
एक लैब सॉल्व कर लेते हैं
हम पास एक लैब थी
वैसे हां ये रहा वेब कैश पॉइजनिंग वाया
एमिगस रिक्वेस्ट चलिए एमगस रिक्वेस्ट प
चलते हैं यहां
पे वी केम हियर ठीक है हम यहां प आ चुके
हैं बहुत बढ़िया अब देखो यहां पे यहां पर
क्या करना
है दिस लैब इज वल्नरेबल टू वेब कैश
पॉइजनिंग ड्यू टू डिस्क्रिपेंसी इन हाउ द
कैश एंड बैक एंड एप्लीकेशन हैंडल द एमगस
रिक्वेस्ट एंड अनसस्पेक्टिंग यूजर
रेगुलरली विजिट्स द साइट्स होम पेज ठीक है
टू सॉल्व द लैब पॉइजन द कैश सो द होम पेज
एग्जीक्यूट्स अलर्ट डॉक्यूमेंट कुकी इन द
विक्टिम्स ब्राउजर तो यह होम पेज
एग्जीक्यूट करना चाहिए इसके कहने का मतलब
यह है अलट डॉक्यूमेंट कुकी करना चाहिए ठीक
है तो आपको अगर समझ में नहीं आ रहा है ऐसे
लैब्स जब तो आप सॉल्यूशन देख सकते हैं
स्टेप्स जो होते हैं ये आप देख सकते हैं
कैसे-कैसे स्टेप्स है इनको फॉलो कर सकते
हैं अदर वाइज आप पहले खुद भी ट्राई आउट कर
सकते हैं तो इसके लिए मुझे क्या चाहिए
मुझे चाहिए होगा बब शूट तो मैं बब शूट को
स्टार्ट कर देता हूं पहले बब शूट को यहां
पर स्टार्ट करते
हैं ओके नेक्स्ट
नेक्स्ट
चलिए यहां पर चलते प्रॉक्सी प इंटरसेप्ट
को ऑफ कर देते हैं चलिए अच्छी बात है यहां
प चलते हैं यहां पर हम करते हैं एक्सेस द
लैब तो लैब को एक्सेस कर लेते एक बार
पहले लेट्स एक्सेस द लप
ल लेट इट ओपन
गाइस क्या हुआ भाई लाब ओपन होने में इतना
टाइम लगता
है इससे आपको जल्दी समझ में आएगा ये नहीं
ओपन हो रहा है यार अच्छा ये वाला ओपन हो
गया चलो चलो हां तो ये ओपन हो चुका है नॉट
सॉल्वड है हमारा लैब अभी फिलहाल इसको
ट्राई करेंगे सॉल्व करने का तो व्हाट वी
विल डू तो अब सबसे पहले अ यहां पे बब शूट
मोड ऑन कर लेंगे पहले प्रॉक्सी जो है बब
शूट पे चेंज कर लेता हूं मैं यहां पे एंड
अब मैं इसको रीलोड कर लेता हूं इस पेज को
रीलोड करता हूं तो यहां पे एसटीटीपी
हिस्ट्री में जो है हमारा अ बेसिकली जो भी
पेज है यहां पे आएगा यहां पे जो हम पेज को
लोड कर रहे हैं तो यहां पे आपको आपके पास
ये आ रहा है राइट सो 0
a43 एंड ऑल तो यही वाला है हमारा आईडी 0a
43 वाली ठीक है तो हमारे पास एक रिक्वेस्ट
ये रिक्वेस्ट आ रही है देखो यहां पे
रिक्वेस्ट आ रही है यहां पे ये रिक्वेस्ट
आ गई सारी मैं क्या करता हूं एक रिक्वेस्ट
को राइट क्लिक करके रिपीटर को सेंड कर
देता हूं ये वाली जो मेन रिक्वेस्ट है
हमारी होम पेज की जो हमारी जो होम पेज है
हमारी ये वाली लैब वाली इसको हमने रिपीटर
को भेज दिया ठीक है अब यहां पे मैं गो पे
क्लिक करता हूं गो पे क्लिक करता हूं हमें
यहां रिस्पांस आ रहा है बहुत बढ़िया 200
ओके रिस्पांस आ रहा है और यहां जब
रिस्पांस आएगा तो आपको यहां पे दिखेगा एक
एक्स कैश नाम का हेडर रिस्पांस हेडर जो
यहां मिस आ रहा है यानी कि कैस्ड वर्जन
हमें यह पेज नहीं मिला है यह पेज जो हमें
मिला है यह ओरिजिनल पेज है क्योंकि एक्स
कैश जो हेडर है यह आपको बता रहा है कि यह
पेज ओरिजिनल है या मिस्ड है सिंपल मतलब
ओरिजिनल है या कैस्ड वर्जन ऑफ पेज है अगर
ये कैस्ड वर्जन ऑफ पेज होता तो ये यहां पर
पे मिस की जगह हिट लिखा रहेगा सिंपल मतलब
ये एक्स हिट हो गया एक्स कैश यानी कि ये
कैश वर्जन है तो अब कैश वर्जन कैसे होगा
तो मैंने एक बार जब इसको इंटरेक्ट किया तो
ये मिस आया अब मैं दूसरी बार जब सेम पेज
से इंटरेक्ट करूंगा जैसे मैं डि फ्रक्स के
केस में कर रहा था एक बार किया तो सर्व हो
गया दूसरी बार रीलोड किया तो कैश वाली
वर्जन पेज मुझे मिली तो मैं क्या करता हूं
देखना एक्स कैश वाली ये चीज ध्यान रखना
मैं यहां पे फिर से एक बार और इस
रिक्वेस्ट को भेजता हूं गो पे क्लिक
करूंगा अगेन ये मिस आ रहा है क्योंकि मुझे
ओरिजिनल वर्जन ही मिल रहा है अभी पेज का
मैं फिर से गो पे क्लिक
करूंगा इस बार मुझे यह एक कैश हिट आ गया
क्योंकि इस बार जो मुझे यह पेज मिला है ना
ये ओरिजिनल सर्वर से रिक्वेस्ट लेके नहीं
आया ये पेज सर्वर ने ये रिस्पांस नहीं
किया ये कैज मेमोरी से रिस्पांस आपको मिला
है ठीक है यह कैज मेमोरी से रिस्पांस मिला
है यह समझ में आ रहा है यह एक्स कैश हिट
हो गया पहले मिस हो रहा था सबसे जल्दी
बताइए सबको समझ में आ रहा है एवरीवन लेट
मी नो फास्ट जल्दी जल्दी जल्दी जल्दी हरी
आप हरी आप हरी आप इतना समझ में आ रहा है
एक ची को समझते चलेंगे तभी समझ में आएगा
जहां छूटा वहां समझ से दिमाग से निकल
जाएगा
आपके
सॉरी बताइए जल्दी जल्दी
जल्दी यह प्रैक्टिकली थोड़ा समझ रहे
कांसेप्ट को प्रैक्टिकली समझ रहे
हैं ठीक है यह हिट हो गया इस
बार भाई आप लोग जवाब नहीं दोगे सभी लोग तो
मजा नहीं आता है एक तो यार आप लोग 100
वाला अटें का टारगेट नहीं पूरा करते ऊपर
से जवाब भी नहीं देते तो यार मुझे दुखी
क्यों कर रहे हो तुम लोग चलो ठीक है यस
समझ में आ गया यह चीज ठीक है कथन मास्क
रजत निशांत आरसी टेक लोकेश दीपक सभी लोगों
को समझ में आ चलिए अच्छी बात है अब हम
क्या करते हैं यहां
पर अरे भाईल इंजेक्शन है क्या यार क्या
तुम भी यार कुछ भी बोल रहे हो क्या लिखा
है टॉपिक आज का
इंजेक्शन कहां से है यार ये ह देखो अब हम
यहां पर एक होस्ट हेडर इंजेक्शन वाली जो
चीज है ना वो ट्राई करते हैं क्या करते
हैं हम क्या करते हैं यहां पे होस्ट को
चेंज करते हैं होस्ट जो हमारा ये है ना
इसको चेंज करते
हैं ठीक है होस्ट को चेंज करते क्या करते
हैं बंगड कॉ बंगड कॉ करते हैं बंगड कॉ
करके यहां पे मैं इसको गो प क्लिक कर देता
हूं गो प क्लिक किया मैंने जैसे ही मैंने
गो प क्लिक किया यहां प ये आ रहा है फ 04
गेटवे टाइम आउट ठीक है मतलब दिस इज
गेटिंग
एक्चुअली फिल्टर्ड हमारा जो यह bing.com
हमने होस्ट चेंज किया तो यह फिल्टर्ड हो
रहा है यानी कि बेसिकली यहां पे यह
वैलिडेशन कीज आ रही है सर्वर के साइड से
कि भाई होस्ट तो कोई चेंज नहीं हो रहा है
इसलिए हमें कोई यहां पे एरर आ गई सर्वर
एरर एंड यह चीज हमारा काम यहां पे फिलहाल
नहीं कर रहा है ठीक है बस सिंपल सा फंडा
है चलिए अब मैं क्या करता हूं bing.com
को अगेन मैं प्रीवियस वाली पे जाता हूं
यहां पे यहां पे इसी तरीके से जाते हैं अब
हम यहां पे क्या ट्राई करते हैं व्हाट वी
आर गोइंग टू डू मैं इसके अलावा एक और
होस्ट डालता हूं एंड यहां पे bing.com
डालता हूं अगेन मल्टीपल होस्ट डालता हूं
मैं यहां पे गो पे क्लिक करता हूं जैसे ही
मैंने गो पे क्लिक किया देखो यहां पे 200
ओके आ रहा है यहां पे एंड ये आ रही है कैश
मिश वाली चीज आ रही है ठीक है मिस मिस आई
बट यहां जैसे ही हमने ये चीज किया एक और
होस्ट डाल के bing.com किया हमें यहां पे
एक पाथ मिला है एसआरसी bing.com
स्सो j
tracking.com इज गेटिंग रिफ्लेक्टेड याद
रखना डबल कोट क्लोजिंग के अंदर में यह
bing.com हमारा रिफ्लेक्ट हो रहा
है यह सबसे बड़ी चीज है सो यह यहां पे
रिफ्लेक्ट हो रहा है वेब कश यह जो चीज है
bing.com ये यहां पर रिफ्लेक्ट हो रहा है
बट यह एक्स कैश मिस आ रहा है य अब मैं
यहां पे गो प क्लिक करूंगा अगे
लेट्स
सी अगेन यह मिस आ रहा है अगेन मैं गो पर
क्लिक करूंगा दिस टाइम इट इज गेटिंग हिट
कैश हिट हो रहा है अब ये मुझे कैश वर्जन
ऑफ पेज मिल रहा है एंड यह एक पर्टिकुलर
रिक्वेस्ट जो है ना इस पेज पर हमारे
रिफ्लेक्ट हो रही है यह चीज बड क यह हमारा
अफेक्टेड पेज है कौन सा स् रिसोर्सेस
जंग बस तो हमें एक अफेक्टेड पेज मिला है
चलिए यह बहुत अच्छी बात
है अब यहां पे चलते हैं क्या है अब हमारा
टू सॉल्व द पॉइजन द कैश सो होम पेज
एग्जीक्यूट अ ड्यूड अब इसको हम पॉइजन
करेंगे भैया तो अब यहां पे जब मैं यहां पे
प्रॉक्सी पे चलता हूं एसटीटीपी हिस्ट्री
पे मैं चलता हूं यहां पे तो एसटीटीपी
हिस्ट्री पे जब आप जाएंगे तो यहां पे आपको
एक चीज दिखेगी चलिए नीचे आते हैं देखते
हैं यहां पे कुछ दिख रहा है कि नहीं हां
अभी तो कुछ नहीं दिख रहा है तो अब हम यह
वापस से रिपीटर पे चलते हैं यहां पे एंड
दिस टाइम व्हाट वी आर गोइंग टू डू वी आर
गोइंग टू चेंज द पाथ यह वाली पाथ जो हमारा
अफेक्टेड पाथ है इसको मैं कॉपी कर लेता
हूं यहां पे कॉपी किया रिसोर्स वाली पात
को यहां पे मैं चलता हूं लैब पे यहां पे
ठीक है वेब कैश पॉइजनिंग लैब पे यहां
एक्सप्लोइट सर्वर प चलते हैं ठीक है
एक्सप्लोइट सर्वर पर चलते हैं बहुत बढ़िया
वी वेंट टू एक्सप्लोइट सर्वर यहां पे यह
जो फाइल है जो अफेक्टेड फाइल था हमारा उस
पाथ को हम यहां पर लिख देते हैं स्
रिसोर्सेस जंग ज ठीक है यह हमने कर दिया य
पर लिख दिया अच्छी बात
है यह वाली य स्ल रिसोर्सेस वाली ठीक है
अफेक्टेड वाली य पर लिख दी नीचे आएंगे य
पर बॉडी में हम यहां पर एक्सेसेस का एक
पेलो डाल देते हैं जो यहां पर अलर्ट
करवाना है हमें यही डाल देते अल
डॉक्यूमेंट कुकी हम अपने इस चीज में किसम
एक्सप्लोइट स में अब हम इसको यहां पर
स्टोर कर देते हैं वी आर गोइंग टू स्टोर
इट स्टोर पर क्लिक किया डन अब बब शूट में
चलते हैं प्रॉक्सी प चल चलते हैं यहां पे
हमने किया अब हम एसटीडीपी हिस्ट्री जो है
यहां पे यहां पे कुछ चीज हम देखेंगे अभी
तो फिलहाल कुछ नहीं है यहां पे एक
एक्सप्लॉरस पलाइट वाली जो पाथ है वो यहां
पे ओपन हुई है यहां पे ठीक है तो यहां पे
आपको दिख रही है यहां पे
एक्सप्लॉरर गोइंग टू
डू व्हाट वी आर गोइंग टू डू यहां पे हमने
ये चीज कर दिया स्टोर कर दिया यहां पे अब
हम ये एक्सप्लोइट वाली जो हमारी पाथ है
इसको इस यूआरएल को इस डोमेन को कॉपी कर
लेते हैं एंड कॉपी करने के बाद हम बब शट प
चलते हैं रिपीटर पे एंड यहां जो हमारा
होस्ट है bing.com यह जो हमारा होस्ट है
bing.com ठीक है इसको हम रिप्लेस कर देते
हैं एक्सप्लोइट हमारा जो है पेज पाथ उससे
रिप्लेस कर देते हैं जिसमें हमने यह वाली
ऑलरेडी पाथ दे रखी है एंड एक एक्सेसेस का
पेलोड अलर्ट वाला जो है वो डाल के रखा हुआ
है ठीक है आई एम गुड नि शर्क यह वाली हमने
रिप्लेस कर दी और हमने अब होस्ट को क्या
किया यहां पे पॉइजन कर दि यहां पे होस्ट
इंजेक्ट करके हमने एक्सप्लोइट वाली यूआरएल
जो है यहां पे डाल दी है ठीक है चलो ये तो
चीज हो गई बट इसके पहले हम क्या करेंगे ना
हम यहां
पे जो ये एक्स कैश आ रही थी एक्स
कैश यहां पे हिट आ रहा था इसको हम क्या
करेंगे ना एक बार अन हिट करेंगे इसको हम
यहां पे एक बार क्या करेंगे यहां पे स्लैश
यहां पर देके क्वेश्चन मार्क देके ठीक है
और यहां पे कैश बस्टर पैरामीटर लगाएंगे
कोई भी कैश बस्टर पैरामीटर लगा सकते हो
कैश बस्टर पैरामीटर का मतलब क्या है एक
फ्रेश क्वेरी करना ताकि जो कैशिंग हुई है
वो चीज वहां से हट जाए तो मैं यहां पे गो
पे क्लिक करूंगा तो यहां पे अगेन मिस आ
रहा है ठीक है मिस ये मिस हो चुका अब कैश
बस्टिन पैरामीटर हटा दो मतलब उ वो सिर्फ
कैश को हटाने के लिए था अब यहां पे मिस आ
रही है अब हमने यहां पे bing.com के जगह
पे
हम यहां प एक्सप्लॉयड वाली चीज यहां पर
डाल देते हैं एक्सप्लोइट वाला हमारा ये
हमने डाल दिया अब यहां पर हम गो प क्लिक
करेंगे गो प क्लिक हमने किया जैसे हमने गो
पे क्लिक किया अब आपको दिख रहा होगा कि
यहां पे एक्सप्लोइट सर्वर का लिंक आ चुका
है एसआरसी के अंदर में ट्रैकिंग जए और
यहां प एक्स कैश मिस आ रहा है अब हम एक
बार और गो पे क्लिक करेंगे अब यहां जैसे
ही गो प क्लिक करेंगे हिट आ रहा है एंड
व्हेन यू विल ओपन दिस एक्सप्लोइट सर्वर
यहां पे आ जाएगा कांग्रेचुलेशन यू सॉल्व द
लैब कांग्रेचुलेशन यू सॉल्व द लैब समझ में
आ रहा है तो हमने यहां पर लैब सॉल्व कर
लिया क्यों क्योंकि हमने कैश को पॉइजन
किया पॉइजन कैसे किया हमने एक एक्सस का
पेलो डाला था एक्सप्लोइट सर्वर के अंदर
में अ डॉक्यूमेंट ककी अब यह कैसे टेस्ट
होगा तो यहां पे
बेसिकली यह कैसे होगा यह मैं आपको दिखा
देता हूं यहां पर बेसिकली क्या करेंगे हम
यह जो होस्ट है यह वाली रिक्वेस्ट जो है
इसको हम राइट क्लिक करके हैं शो रिस्पांस
इन ब्राउजर करके कॉपी कर लेते हैं एंड
इसको ब्राउजर में ओपन करने की कोशिश करते
हैं लेट्स ओपन इट इन द ब्राउजर ओपन करते
हैं यहां पर ब्राउजर में जैसे ही हम
ब्राउजर में ओपन करेंगे यहां पर एक अलर्ट
आ जाएगा जो कि यहां पर आ रहा हैट डॉट सेज
एंड इस तरह का एक पॉप अप आ रहा
है ठीक है दिस टाइप ऑफ पॉप अप
केम ठीक है यह समझ में आ रहा है तो हमें
यहां पर पॉप अप आ चुका और हमारा लैब जो है
यहां पर बेसिकली सॉल्व हो चुका है जो हमें
चाहिए
था गट
इट
यह समझ में
आया गट इट
गाइस सभी लोग बताइए प्लीज एक
बार
मुझे एक एक्सकल इंजेक्शन का पूरा डेटा बेस
मिल चुका
है
बट बट उन लोगों का कोई बग बांटी प्रोग्राम
नहीं है क्या करू सिंपल है उनको मेल करके
रिपोर्ट करने की कोशिश करो अगर वह रिप्लाई
कर रहे हैं नहीं करेंगे तो कोई बात नहीं
उनको उसमें कुछ नहीं कर सकते तुम उसको
छोड़ दो सिंपल सा बंदा है यह लैब हमारा
सॉल्व हुआ वेब कैश पॉ नहीं का बट आपको समझ
में आया ना क्या हो रहा है यहां पे हमने
कैश को पॉइजन किया एक हमारा जो होस्ट यहां
पे रिफ्लेक्ट हो रहा था यहां
पे सॉरी यहां पे रिफ्लेक्ट हो रहा
था ठीक है तो उसको उसमें हमने एक अल
डॉक्यूमेंट डॉट कुकी वाली जो एक्सस पेलोड
है वो डाली एंड उसको जब हमने मिस करा था
तब नहीं जब हमने वापस से जब कैस्ट वर्जन
को हिट कराया कैस्ड कॉपी लाया यहां पे तो
ये यहां पे लैब सॉल्व हो चुका एंड हमारा
जो जावास्क्रिप्ट कोड था वो एग्जीक्यूट हो
गया यह समझ में आ रहा है
सबको यह समझ में आ रहा
है एवरीवन गट स पहले जैसा जोश नहीं है
आपकी क्लास में कोई बात नहीं ये तो आपकी
गलती है पहली जैसी जोश नहीं है जोश लाओ
यार आपकी गलती है भाई ये जोश नहीं लाओगे
मैं क्या कर सकता हूं इसमें सीखना सीखने
में हमेशा जोश होना चाहिए
भाई य समझ में आ
गया इसके अलावा हमें इसके लिए हमें हमको
सर्वर की नीड होगी जो आपने एक्सप्ला सर्वर
में ऐड किया वहां बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बिल्कुल
खुद की बिल्कुल बिल्कुल ओबवियसली बिल्कुल
सही आई एम ए न्यू स्टूडेंट सर आप बिहार से
हो बहुत अच्छा लगा चलो बहुत अच्छी बात
है वन बॉय इज मिस लीडिंग और
नाम बता दो या नंबर बता दो नंबर का लास्ट
डिजिट फाइव डिजिट हटा देंगे उसको रूल फॉलो
नहीं कर ठीक
है
चलिए एवरीवन
गेट गेटिंग एवरीवन
गेटिंग सिंपल सा फंड थाय इसको वेब कैस्ट
पॉइजनिंग बोलते हैं या हमने वेब कस्ट पॉज
कर लिया ठीक है चलिए इसका एक और एग्जांपल
समझते हैं एक एक और समझते हैं वेब कैश
पॉइजनिंग कहां गई वेब कैश पॉइजनिंग वेब
कैश पॉइजनिंग पे चलते
हैं हेलो सर यू आर ग्रेट थैंक यू थैंक यू
थैंक यू थैंक
यू चलिए वेब कैस्ट पॉइजनिंग के लैब्स पे
चलते हैं व्यू ऑल वेब कैस्ट पॉइजनिंग
लैब्स जिनको नहीं समझ में आया दोबारा एक
बार रिकॉर्डिंग देखिएगा आपको समझ में आ
जाएगा लेट्स गो टू द वेब कैश पॉइजनिंग
लैब्स
देन पासवर्ड रिसेट अटैक पासवर्ड रिसेट जो
पॉइजनिंग अटैक है वह भी बहुत शानदार है तो
मैं एक चलता हूं यहां पर अन कीड हेडर
प यह वाली चीज पर चलते हैं यह लैब पर चलते
हैं ठीक है दिस लैब इ रेबल टू वेब कैस्ट
पॉइजनिंग बिकॉज इट हैंडल्स इनपुट मैं क्या
करता हूं बब शूट में चलता हूं यहां पर
इसको मैं क्लियर कर देता हूं प्रॉक्सी प
चलता हूं एपी हिस्ट्री को मैं क्लियर कर
देता हूं क्लियर
हिस्ट्री ठीक
है
नंबर बता दो यार लास्ट का जो ग्रुप जो
ग्रुप में दिक्कत कर रहे हैं उनका लास्ट
का पांच डिजिट बता दो
ना या वहां पर हमें टैग कर दो ना ग्रुप
में व ग्रुप में फिर हम उनको कर देंगे लव
फ्रॉम आसाम लव फ्रॉम इंडिया ब्रदर लव
फ्रॉम
बिहार ठीक है अब यहां पे क्या दिस लैब इज
वल्नरेबल टू वेब कैस्ट पॉइजनिंग ठीक है
वेब कैस्ट पॉइजनिंग से वल्नरेबल है इट
हैंडल्स इनपुट फ्रॉम अन कीड हेडर अन कीड
हेडर याद है अन कीड हेडर का मतलब क्या
होता है जिनका
वो गेट और होस्ट को छोड़ के इन एन अनसेफ
वे एन अनसस्पेक्टिंग यूजर रेगुलरली
विजिट्स द साइट्स होम पेज टू सॉल्व दिस
लैब पॉइजन द कैश विथ रिस्पांस दैट
एग्जीक्यूट अलट डॉक्यूमेंट कुकी इन द
विजिटर्स
ब्राउजर ठीक है इन द विजिटर्स ब्राउजर समझ
में आ गया सर मेरे जीएफ को आपका हेयर
स्टाइल बहुत अच्छा लगता है ये क्या भाई ये
क्या ये कौन सी बात है यार ये कौन सी बात
करते हो तुम
लोग
चलिए बोर्ड दो तारीख खत्म हो गया बहुत
बढ़िया चलिए अब यहां पे देखते हैं यहां पे
हिंट क्या है हिंट में देख लेते हैं दिस
लैब सपोर्ट्स एक्स फॉरवर्ड होस्ट चलिए
अच्छी बात है तो अब इसको एक बार ट्राई
करते हैं एक्सेस द
लैब लैब को एक्सेस कर लेते
हैं नंबर रिवील मत करो लास्ट फाइव डिजिट
बता दो नंबर का लास्ट फाइव डिजिट ओनली लेट
अस
नो तो इसको ओपन करते हैं
पहले लेट इट ओपन
गाइस चलिए ओपन हो
चुका
सॉरी यहां पर आ रहा होगा हमारा
0 करके यह लब है ठीक है यह आ गया गेट
रिक्वेस्ट य पर एडी हिस्ट्री के अंदर में
ओके राइट क्लिक करते हैं य पर सेंड टू
रिपीटर करते
हैं सर मुझे 20 के का बाउंट मिला आपके
क्लास से ओहो ग्रेट कांग्रेचुलेशन
चिकू तो यार लिंकन पर डाल के टैग तो किया
करो कम से कम तुम लोग टैग टग करके कम से
कम टैग तो किया करो डिफक साइबर सिक्योरिटी
को या मुझे टैग कर दिया
करो लोगों को भी तो पता चले यार कि तुम
लोग कर रहे यहां
से कांग्रेचुलेशन बाय द
वे लास्ट सेवन डिजिट है ओके मैं एक
बार देख लेता
हूं
ओके मैं इसको बैन कर देता
चलिए रिमूव कर दिया सो समवन
[संगीत]
वास रिमूव हो गए जो स्पैम कर रहे थे ठीक
है चलिए यहां पर हमने रिक्वेस्ट को क्या
किया सो व ग्रुप जो हमारा बग बाउंट का ्
ग्रुप है कम्युनिटी है आप उसको
डिस्क्रिप्शन में लिंक आपको मिल जाएगा इस
वीडियो के भी इस लाइव के भी वहां से ग्रुप
जवाइन कर सकते हैं फॉर एवरीवन वहां पे अभी
करेंटली जो है हमारे 838 मेंबर्स हैं 838
मेंबर्स हैं हमारे
ओके तो यहां पर मैं स्क्रीन शेयर करता हूं
यहां पर स्टार्ट स्क्रीन
शेयर यह
रही सो यह हमारा एक ् कम्युनिटी ग्रुप है
जहां पे आपको यहां पे दिख रहा होगा शायद
जिसको मैंने क्रिएट किया था डि फ्रक्स बग
बग बाउंट हंटर्स यहां पे 8 41 मेंबर्स है
करेंटली और टोटल ग्रुप की कैपेसिटी जो है
वो शायद
1024 या कुछ 1000 कुछ होती है शायद अब नया
जो है तो अगर आपको जवाइन करना है तो किसी
भी डिस्क्रिप्शन में अ लाइक किसी भी तरह
का किसी भी जो हमारी अभी लाइव सेशन चल रही
है आज वाली कल वाली उसके डिस्क्रिप्शन में
जाइएगा इसका
[संगीत]
तो हम अब यहां पर आ चुके हैं लैब पे एंड
हमने क्या
किया क्या बोल रहे हो भाई सर ग्रुप सिर्फ
इंडिया के लिए तो नहीं है ना क्योंकि वहां
पर इंडियन पाकिस्तान को लेकर लड़ाइया हो
रही है नहीं नहीं कोई इंडिया और स्पेशली
किसी किसी कंट्री के लिए नहीं है इंडिया
पाकिस्तान बांग्लादेश नेपाल यूके यूएस
ऑस्ट्रेलिया सब जितने कंट्रीज है जो भी बग
बाउटी हंटर्स एस्पायरिंग सब आ स ठीक आप
लोग इंडिया पाकिस्तान को लेकर लड़ाई मत
कीजिए प्लीज वहा सीखने के लिए है सीखिए
उससे ज्यादा कुछ मत कीजिए सीखने से अच्छा
कुछ नहीं होता सीखने से ज्यादा आपको कुछ
नहीं करना
है रिपोर्ट कर दो भाई रिपोर्ट कर दो ललित
रिपोर्ट कर
दो नहीं सही नंबर रिमूव किया मैंने फैजल
जो नवेद है 33431 बिल्कुल सही मैंने नंबर
बिल्कुल सही नंबर मैंने यहां पर रिमूव
किया है फैजल नवीद जिसने फालतू की चीजें
डाली हुई थी फैजल नावी द ने वही चीज ये
क्रैकिंग का पता नहीं क्या-क्या फालतू चीज
डाल रहा
था
तो मैं यह भी रिमूव कर देता हूं यहां
से
याके
चलिए
अबे तुम्हें कहां किया यार आरटेक अभी
थोड़ी ना तुम्हे रिमूव किया है टेंशन मत
लो तुमहे कहां किया आरटेक तुम नहीं हो
क्या अभी ग्रुप में नहीं हो क्या
आरटेक अभी ग्रुप में हो कि नहीं हो पहले य
बताओ
आर्टेक अभी ग्रुप में हो ना तुम
आर्टेक वेबसाइट डिफेंस पर वीडियो बनाओ
आएगा भाई सब आएगा टेंशन मत लो गाइड कीजिए
मुझे वेब
एप्लीकेशन अरे ऐड किया तो था तुम्हें यार
दोबारा ऐड तो हुए था ना तुम आरटेक दोबारा
ऐड हुए था ना ग्रुप
में दोबारा ऐड हो तो गए थे भाई ग्रुप में
तो तुम दोबारा ऐड हो गए
थे
99906 तुम ऐड हो ग्रुप में यार
दोबारा कोई बात नहीं ऐड हो जाओगे कोई कोई
दिक्कत नहीं तुम ऐड हो
जाओगे दोबारा ऐड हो जाओगे ठीक है चलिए अब
यहां पर आ जाते हैं हम लैब को सॉल्व कर
रहे थे पहले इस पर आ जाते हैं उधर ज्यादा
इधर उधर भटकते नहीं है ये लैब है हमारा
लैब में क्या है लैब वल्नरेबल है वेब कैश
पॉइजनिंग से अल डॉक्यूमेंट कुकी वाली चीज
हमें करनी है तो नाउ वी आर हियर सो अब हम
क्या करते हैं रिपीटर को भेज दिया हमने ये
वाली लैब का जो ये चीज है रिपीटर को यहां
प गो प क्लिक कर देते हैं जैसे ही गो प
हमने क्लिक किया वी विल गेट द रिस्पांस सो
जस्ट वेट वील गट द रिस्पांस एक्स कैश यहां
मिस आ रहा है चलिए अच्छी बात है अब यहां
पे क्या करना है यहां हिंट में एक्स
फॉरवार्डेड होस्ट जो है वो सपोर्ट कर रहा
है चलिए कोई बात नहीं कोई दिक्कत नहीं
यहां पे एक्सप्लोइट सर्वर प चलते हैं अब
हम यहां पे क्या कर देते हैं होस्ट के बाद
यहां पर हम कर देते हैं एक्स फॉर
वर्डेड होस्ट एंड इसमें हम bing.com डाल
ठीक है बड क डाला य पर गो पर क्लिक किया
लेट्स सी जैसे हमने गो प क्लिक किया यहां
पर अभे हमें यहां पर कोई रिजल्ट मिला क्या
बंगड कॉ का कुछ
ऐसा कोई रिजल्ट हमें नहीं मिला हमें ट गेट
एनीथिंग ओके कोई बात नहीं यहां
पर हमें य पर कोई रिजल्ट नहीं मिला है बड
क
राइट ओके एक्स फरड हो
है ओएस स्टूडियो डिस्कनेक्टिंग क्यों आ
रहा है
भाई व्हाई इट इज ओएस स्टूडियो
डिस्कनेक्टिंग लेट मी
सी ओके री कनेक्शन सक्सेसफुल हो चुका है
चलिए अच्छी बात है यहां पे तो अब यहां पे
व्हाट वी आर गोइंग टू
डू यहां पे हम थोड़ा सा हिंट लेते हैं कि
क्या करना है यहां पे हिंट में यहां पे
लेते हैं तो यहां पे कैश बस्टर यूज हो रहा
है ठीक है कोई बात नहीं एक्स फॉरवार्डेड
होस्ट में कोई सा भी एक होस्ट ले लेते हैं
यहां पे एंड डायनेमिक जनरेट एक चीज कर रहा
है ठीक है तो यहां पे हम एक काम कर देते
हैं जो गेट रिक्वेस्ट है यहां पे यहां पे
हमें कैश बस्टर पैरामीटर ला रहे हैं
क्वेश्चन माक कैश बस्टर इक्वल ट 1 2 3 4
पैरामीटर हमने ला दिया 1 2 3 कुछ भी लिख
दो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है यहां पे एक्स
फॉरवार्डेड जो
है इसको जो है फिलहाल हटा देते हैं यहां
पे कैश बस्टर पैरामीटर लगा के गो पे क्लिक
कर देते हैं जैसे ही गो प क्लिक करेंगे
कैश यहां पे मिस हो रहा है ठीक है अब यहां
पे हम डालते हैं एक्स फॉरवार्डेड bing.com
यहां पे मैं गो पे क्लिक कर देता हूं जैसे
ही मैंने गो पे क्लिक किया यहां पे हमें
आपको मिल रहा होगा आपको दिख रहा है यहां
पे एक सोर्स मिल रहा है रिसोर्सेस लब हेडर
जए लब हैरड जए यह वाली चीज एक मिल रही है
एक पाथ हमें मिल रहा है ठीक है यहां पे
एंड एक पाथ हमें मिल रहा है ये वाली लैब
का जो यूआरएल है उसके बाद रिसोर्सेस j
tracking.in यूज टू डायनेमिक जनरेट एन
एब्सलूट यूआरएल फॉर
[प्रशंसा]
इंपोर्टिडोरा
है हमें यहां पर इस वाली पाथ प रिसोर्स जस
ट्रैकिंग जस इसको यह बेसिकली एग्जीक्यूट
कर रहा है यहां प इस पाथ को तो अब हम क्या
कर देते हैं यहां पे अब हम यहां पर क्या
कर देते हैं इस
वाले बस्टर वाले को हटा देते हैं जो हमारा
कैश बस्टर है कैश बस्टर का यूज इसलिए किया
जाता है ताकि
फ्रेश रिक्वेस्ट की जाए बस बात खत्म कुछ
भी का कर सकते हैं कोई दिक्कत नहीं मैं अ
यहां पर गो प क्लिक कर देता हूं यहां पर
मिस आ रहा है चलिए अच्छी बात है अगेन गो प
क्लिक कर देता हूं अब यह हिट आ रहा है हिट
आ रहा है चलिए अच्छी बात है यहां पे हिट
आया यहां पे अब जैसे ही हिट आया याद
रखिएगा देखिएगा मैं प्रीवियस रिक्वेस्ट
आपको करके दिखा देता
हूं मैं प्रीवियस रिक्वेस्ट कर रहा हूं
यहां पे जब हमने कैश बस्टर लगाया था एंड
यहां पे गो प क्लिक किया था यहां पे कैश
मिस आ रहा है यहां पे मैं यहां प जैसे ही
फिर से गो प क्लिक कर रहा हूं यहां पे कैश
बस्टर हटा हटा देते हैं यहां
पे यहां पे गो पे क्लिक करते
हैं मिस आ रहा है गो पे क्लिक करते हैं अब
यहां पे हिट आ रहा है जैसे ही हिट आ रहा
है यहां पे आपको सोर्स में bing.com
res.in j और हमें अलट क्या करवाना है भैया
अलॉट करवाना है डॉक्यूमेंट ड कुकी यह वाली
एक्सेसेस जो हमें अलट करानी है
जावास्क्रिप्ट यह वाली करा देनी है ठीक है
तो यह हमने इतना कर दिया ट्स फेयर इनफ अब
हम इसको स्टोर पर क्लिक कर देते हैं स्टोर
पर क्लिक किया स्टोर हो गया वेल डन गुड
कोई बात अब हम एक्सप्लोइट वाली जो यूआरएल
है हमारी इसको सर्व करते हैं यहां पर हमने
कॉपी कर लिया हम अपने बब शट प आते हैं अब
हम एक्स फॉरवर्ड bing.com के जगह पर हम
अपनी एक्सप्लोइट जो पेज है उसका यूआरएल
डाल देते हैं एंड देन हम इसको गो पे क्लिक
करते हैं जैसे ही गो पे क्लिक करेंगे पहला
यह मिस आ रहा है ठीक है मिस आया यहां पे
एंड यहां पे आपको दिख रहा होगा एसआरसी के
अंदर में एक्सप्लोइट वाली जो हमारी यूआरएल
आ चुकी है अब एक बार और गो पे क्लिक
करेंगे यह हिट होगा यह हिट हो गया एक्स
कैश जो है हिट होते ही सॉरी हम पेज इस पे
चलते हैं एंड यहां पे आ रहा है
कांग्रेचुलेशन यू सॉल्व द लैब यानी कि
हमारा यह लैब हिट हो चुका है अब हम यहां
राइट क्लिक करके शो रिस्पांस इन ब्राउज़र
करके कॉपी कर लेते हैं एंड यहां पे हम
इसको
ओपन करते हैं एंड हमारा एक पॉप अप आना
चाहिए मेरे ख्याल से अलर्ट वाली लेट्स सी
ये रहा अलर्ट आ गया हमारा जो हमाने एक्सस
अलर्ट अलर्ट वाली जो पेज वो जो हमारा पेल
था अलर्ट आ चुका है हमारा लैब जो है वो
सॉल्व हो चुका है गॉट इट
एवरीवन समझ में आ गया ये हमने सेम वही चीज
किया सिंपल सा फंडा है भाई पहली बार जब
इंटरेक्ट कर रहे हो एक्स कैश मिस आ रहा है
दोबारा करोगे हिट आ जाएगा उसके बाद हम
होस्ट टा इंजेक्शन करेंगे एक होस्ट के जगह
पे पहला हमने डबल होस्ट यूज किया bing.com
फिर हमने वहां पर एक्सप्लोइट वाला पेज का
यूआरएल डाल दिया हमने अब हम यहां पर एक
फॉरवार्डेड होस्ट यूज कर रहे हैं एंड
इसमें हमने एक्सप्लोइट पेज डाला और उसके
बाद पहले मिस वाले कैश प ट्राई किया फिर
हिट वाले पे किया जैसे ही हिट वाले प हमने
किया हमारा यहां पे पॉप अप आ चुका ट्स
इट समझ में आया कि नहीं आया पहले बताइए
वेब कस्ट पॉइजनिंग जल्दी जल्दी जल्दी
जल्दी एवरी
बडी
हां भाई सब एडवांस ही हो है सारा क्लास
एडवांस होता है समझ में आया आप लोगों को
हेलो
विनय कोई बात नहीं
विन
ओके कर दूंगा भाई अभी तो क्लास चल रही है
अभी तो देखो
इधर 40 45 लोग हैं रिप्लाई बहुत सारे लोग
नहीं करते यार क्या दिक्कत है रिप्लाई
करने में बताइए आप ही लोग बताइए क्या
दिक्कत आ रही है रिप्लाई सभी क्यों नहीं
करते
हैं लेट मी नो व्हाई एवरी व्हाई नॉट
एवरीवन
रिप्लाई रिकॉर्डिंग एक बार देखिएगा
शायद ज्यादा क्लियर हो जाएगा रिकॉर्डिंग
से भी ठीक है तो ये हमने वेब कैश पॉइजनिंग
यहां पे कर ली है इसी के साथ हमने
एक्सेसेस का भी यहां पे अलर्ट जनरेट किया
है सो आपको यह भी समझ में आ गया होगा कि
हम एक्सेसेस को कैसे यहां पे ट्रिगर कर
सकते हैं हाउ वी कैन ट्रिगर द एक्सेसेस
करेंटली हियर ठीक है यहां पे किस किस
तरीके से कर सकते हैं आप यहां पे भी एक्स
फॉरवार्डेड होस्ट में आप जाएंगे यहां पे
तो आप देख रहे हैं एक्स फॉरवर्ड होस्ट में
यहां
पे डबल कोट क्लोजिंग के अंदर में हमारा यह
चीज एग्जीक्यूट हो रहा है तो यह अगर आप
एक्स फॉरवार्डेड होस्ट में यहां पे ये चीज
कर रहे है एक्सप्लोइट वाली तो डबल कोड
क्लोजिंग के अंदर यह पाथ जो है एग्जीक्यूट
हो रहा है राइट तो आप यहां पे भी
डायरेक्टली डबल कोट क्लोजिंग लगा के और
यहां पे स्क्रिप्ट अलर्ट ये टाइप करके एक
बार ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं लाइक स्क्रिप्ट
लिख दिया आपने
अलर्ट वन एंड स्क्रिप्ट क्लोज कर दिया कुछ
इस तरीके का भी आप पे लोट जनरेट कर सकते
हैं ठीक है स्क्रिप्ट अलट वाली जो पे लोट
थी आपकी जो होती है एक्सएसएस की सिंपल सा
जो पेलोड होता है यह आप जनरेट कर सकते हैं
ठीक है यहां पर फिर राइट क्लिक करके शो
रिस्पांस इन ब्राउजर करके कॉपी कर लिया
एंड यहां पर आके यहां पे एक बार ट्राई कर
लेंगे कि हमारा
क्या जनरेट हो रहा है किस तरीके से हो रहा
है ठीक है तो अग जनरेट हो रहा है तो ट्स
इट यह नॉर्मल सी वेबसाइट के लिए भी आप
ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं कोई इसमें बड़ी
रॉकेट साइंस नहीं है
चलिए यह मैं इसको मैं डिलीट कर देता
हूं क्लियर कर देता हूं
चलिए हां पेलोड नहीं है मतलब जावा
स्क्रिप्ट है जावा स्क्रिप्ट है कोड जावा
स्क्रिप्ट को हमने बस यहां पर अलर्ट
करवाया बस और कुछ नहीं य हमने
जावास्क्रिप्ट को अलर्ट करवा लिया है बस
सिंपल कोड को अलर्ट करवाया मतलब पॉप अप
करवा लिया है बस सिंपल सा पेलो है ठीक है
अल डॉक्यूमेंट
कुकी ओके ठीक है तो वही है वही वही पेलो
हो गया हमारा ठीक है वही हमारा पेलोड
है चलिए तो ये तो गया हमारा वेब कैश
पॉइजनिंग अब वहां यहां से बैक टू द टॉपिक
चलते हैं अब एक बहुत शानदार चीज पढ़ते हैं
पासवर्ड रिसेट पॉइजनिंग वी आर गोइंग टू सी
पासवर्ड रिसेट पॉइजनिंग तो होस्ट हेडर में
चलते हैं यहां पे होस्ट हेडर में चलते हैं
वापस से एडवांस टॉपिक्स के अंदर होस्ट
हेडर ये एडवांस टॉपिक्स के अंदर आता है
एटीडी प होस्ट हेडर याद रखिएगा जो हम कर
रहे हैं अभी
अब चलते हैं शानदार चीज पासवर्ड रिसेट
पॉइजनिंग पे
चलिए अब यहां पे आ चुके हैं अब पासवर्ड
रिसेट पॉइजनिंग कैसे काम करता है मैं आपको
यह समझा देता हूं ठीक है इसका एक सिंपल सा
मैं आपको एग्जांपल देता हूं ठीक है
पासवर्ड रिसेट पॉइजनिंग कैसे काम करती है
अब जैसे मान लो मैं यहां पे इसको बंद कर
देता हूं पासवर्ड
रिसेट पॉइजनिंग अब मान
लो मेरा एक अकाउंट है मेरा कोई अकाउंट बना
हुआ है
जैसे कि मैं कोई सा भी एक अकाउंट ओपन कर
लेता हूं मैंने एक वेबसाइट ओपन
किया ठीक है इनका कोई एक दूसरा वाला ओपन
कर लेते हैं कोई बात
नहीं ओके डीजे अभी
ग्रेट मैंने ये ओपन कर लिया ठीक है अब
यहां पर कुछ लॉगिन वगैरह कुछ है या नहीं
है
लॉगइन का कुछ समझ में नहीं आ रहा इसमें
तो पनि स्मार्ट प चलते
हैं यहां आ जाते हैं अब यहां पर जैसे यूजर
अकाउंट है लॉगिन प चलते हैं यहां पे अब
जैसे लॉगिन प हम गए ना तो हम क्या करते
हैं फॉरगेट पासवर्ड पर क्लिक कर देते हैं
अगर हमें पासवर्ड रिसेट करना होता है
जनरली तो हम क्या करते हैं किसी भी अकाउंट
का फॉरगेट पासवर्ड पर क्लिक करते हैं जैसे
ही फॉरगेट पासवर्ड पर क्लिक करते हैं
व्हाट हैपेंस यहां ईमेल आईडी डालने के लिए
बोला जाता है कि ईमेल आईडी डालिए तो मैं
यहां पे क्या कर देता हूं एक ईमेल आईडी
डाल देता हूं ठीक है कोई भी एक पासवर्ड ट
यहां पे कोई एक ईमेल आईडी डालता हूं चलिए
तो मैंने क्या किया ये वाली एक ईमेल ईमेल
ले ली और यहां पे मैं सबमिट करता हूं अब
इसको मैं इंटरसेप्ट करता हूं पहले
प्रॉक्सी पे चलते हैं इंटरसेप्ट पे चलते
हैं मैं इसको इंटरसेप्ट ऑन कर देता हूं
एंड यहां पे मैं इसको इंटरसेप्ट करूंगा
जैसे ही मैं सबमिट करूंगा ये इंटरसेप्ट हो
जाएगी रिक्वेस्ट एंड फॉरवर्ड करते हैं इस
रिक्वेस्ट को फॉरवर्ड कर देते हैं फॉरवर्ड
कर देते हैं फॉरवर्ड करते हैं फॉरवर्ड
करते करते फॉरवर्ड करते हैं व स्मार्ट ये
वाली आ गई ये रिक्वेस्ट यहां पे इंटरसेप्ट
हो गई यहां पे अब यहां प इंटरसेप्ट जो हुई
है यहां पे गाइस अब आप लोग देखिए यहां पे
ऑनलाइन क्लास लॉगइन ड पीएपी यह वाला एक
रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है एंड यहां पे आपको दिख
रहा होगा यह वाली ईमेल आईडी के लिए
रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है यहां पे एक वेब किट
फॉर्म बाउंड्री यहां पर कुछ एक डाटा आ रही
है य ठीक है एंड कौन सा पेज है फॉरगॉट
पासवर्ड का ठीक है ये चीज आ रही है राइट
क्लिक करता हूं इस रिस्पांसस के रिक्वेस्ट
को करता हूं फॉरवर्ड करता हूं मैं यहां पे
जैसे ही मैंने यहां पर फॉरवर्ड किया यहां
पे यह रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है
फिलहाल नेक्स्ट दूसरे वाले पे चलो नेक्स्ट
करते हैं फॉरवर्ड करते हैं फॉरवर्ड करते
हैं यहां पे फॉरवर्ड करते हैं फॉरवर्ड
हैं यह रिस्पांस आया फ्रॉम वनिक स्मार्ट
यह रिस्पांस जो आया यहां पे आप देखिए यहां
प रिस्पांस नीचे की तरफ चलते हैं रिस्पांस
यहां प नीचे की तरफ आते है यहां
पे इसवा की साइड से यह पूरा का पूरा ये
सर्वर के साइड से आपको रिस्पांस आ रही है
ठीक
है यहां पर
पासवर्ड यहां पर ठीक है यह सवा के साइट से
हमें रिस्पांस आ रही है चलिए अब एक काम
करते
हैं मैं यहां पर नेक्स्ट पर क्लिक करता
हूं
देखो फॉरगॉट पासवर्ड ठीक है यहां नेक्स्ट
करते हैं ठीक है अब यह रिस्पांस आ रहा है
फॉरवर्ड में करता हूं यहां प फॉरवर्ड करता
हूं यहां पे अब यह जो पासवर्ड रिक्वेस्ट
हमने की ना यह सिंपल सा यहां पर हमने जो
सॉरी यहां जो हमने पासवर्ड रि रिक्वेस्ट
की वो कुछ इस तरीके का एक रिक्वेस्ट जनरेट
होता है सिंपल सा एक रिक्वेस्ट मैं आपको
दिखा देता हूं यहां प एक सिंपल सा एक
रिक्वेस्ट जनरेट होता है जैसे मेरी
वेबसाइट जो होगी वो
होगी एक्स वाई जड एक्सवा z.com स् रिसेट
रिसेट पासवर्ड एंड क्वेश्चन मार्क टोकन इ
इक्वल टू समथिंग यह कुछ इस तरह का कुछ एक
टोकन जनरेट होता है ठीक है अब यह जो टोकन
होता है यह हर यूजर अकाउंट का यूनिक टोकन
होता है यानी कि अगर यह टोकन आपके पास हो
इफ यू हैव दिस टोकन तो आप उस पर्टिकुलर
यूजर का पासवर्ड रिसेट कर सकते हो इस
यूआरएल के थ्रू यह यूआरएल आपको इ मिल
जाएगी क्या यह ल कैसे मिलेगी सिंपल कोई सा
भी इंटरसेप्ट करो पासवर्ड रिक्वेस्ट वाली
क्वेरी को एंड यह वाली आपको बेसिकली जो
रिक्वेस्ट है यह मिल जाएगी जैसे कोई सा भी
मैं अकाउंट प एक बार और ट्राई कर लेते हैं
कोई सा भी एक यूआरएल ओपन कर लेते हैं कोई
सा भी एक टारगेट वेबसाइट बताओ छोटी मोटी
कोई जो ई कमर्स वेबसाइट टाइप हो यू कैन
टेल कोई भी बता सकते
हैं
कोई सा
भी वाचिंग फॉर द फर्स्ट टाइम लाइव ग्रेट
सर कोशिश किया करें उर्दू में भी बता दिया
करें इंटरसेप्ट टीसी उर्दू नहीं आती भाई
मेरे को उर्दू कहां से आएगी यार खुद तो
दिमाग लगा लो थोड़ा हिंदी हिंदी आती है
हिंदी
इंग्लिश वही बता सकता हूं उससे ज्यादा तो
मैं नहीं बता सकता कुछ भी आपको समझनी
पड़ेगी दूसरी
हिंदी ठीक
है
चलिए बता दो कोई जल्दी से टारगेट सिंपल सा
टारगेट बताओ
भाई शफाई क्या बता रहे हो छोटी मोटी कोई
कॉमर्स साइट बता दो
ना लोकल साइट बता दो यार जहां पे होती है
चलो ठीक है कोई बात नहीं कोई सी भी साइट
ले लो यार कोई सी भी साइट ले लो जैसे अभी
हमने किया इसको समझो इसको बस सिंपल सा
समझो इस तरह का एक रिक्वेस्ट जाता है अब
अब मान लो लेट्स सपोज लेट्स सपोज मैंने
होस्ट हेडर इंजेक्शन से एक्वा जड कॉ की
जगह पर एक होस्ट डाल दिया जिसमें मैंने
डाल दिया हैरड कॉ अब जब मैंने हैकर कॉ डाल
दिया यहां पे तो जो विक्टिम है उसको
पासवर्ड रिक्वेस्ट लिंक तो
जाएगी विक्टिम को पासवर्ड रिक्वेस्ट लिंक
जाएगी बट उसको यह वाली हैरड कॉ जो वाली जो
रिक्वेस्ट लिंक है वह चली जाएगी समझ में आ
रहा है यह
चीज यह चीज समझ में
नहीं हां राइट राइट कोई बात नहीं कोई बात
नहीं मैं इसको थोड़ा सा और एक्सप्लेन करता
हूं
देखो देखो क्या होता है पासवर्ड रिसेट
कैसे काम करता है इसको थोड़ा समझ लेते हैं
ठीक
है ठीक है द यूजर एंटर्स द यूजर नेम और
ईमेल एड्रेस एंड सबमिट्स अ पासवर्ड रिसेट
रिक्वेस्ट ठीक है द वेबसाइट चेक्स दैट दिस
यूजर एजिस्ट एंड देन जनरेट अ टेंपररी
यूनिक हाई इंट्रॉप टोकन व्हिच इज
एसोसिएटेड विद द यूजर्स अकाउंट ऑन द बैक
एंड यूजर के अकाउंट से एसोसिएटेड होता है
द वेबसाइट सेंड्स एन ईमेल टू द यूजर दैट
कंटेन अ लिंक फॉर रिसेटियर पासवर्ड जैसे
ही रिसेट पासवर्ड क्लिक किया उस यूजर को
मिल जाता है द यूजर्स यूनिक सेंट टोकन इ
इंक्लूडेड तो इस तरह का लिंक में इस तरह
का कुछ यूआरएल होता है ये यूआरएल किस
तरीके इस यूआरएल में एक टोकन होता है ये
इस तरीके का टोकन ठीक है इस तरीके का टोकन
आपको दिख रहा होगा इस तरह का टोकन एक होता
है व्हेन द यूजर विजिट द यूआरएल द वेबसाइट
चेक्स वेदर द प्रोवाइडेड टोकन इज वैलिड जब
यह टोकन वैलिड होगा इसको चेक करेगा
वेबसाइट बस सिंपल सा फंडा है अब देखिए
पासवर्ड रिसेट अटैक
कैसे यह एग्जीक्यूट होता है देखिए द अटैकर
ऑब्टेंड और यूजर नेम एज रिक्वायर्ड एंड
सबमिट अ पासवर्ड रिसेट रिक्वेस्ट ऑन देयर
बिहा तो मैं एक अटैकर हूं मैंने क्या किया
एक पासवर्ड रिसेट जो क्वेरी है वह अटैक
विक्टिम के साइड से मैंने यहां पर डाल
दिया जैसे मैंने फॉरगेट पासवर्ड
किया फॉरगेट पासवर्ड यहां पर
किया कोई एक इसका ओपन कर लेते हैं एक
अकाउंट वनिंग पब्लिकेशन पर देखते
हैं हां वही बात है किसी का टोकन मिल जाए
उसके बाद की तो कहानी है अभी वही बता रहा
हूं मैं
देखो वो टोकन लेना है तुम्हे वो टोकन वही
टोकन फाइंड करना है कैसे फाइंड करना है
देखो दिखा रहा हूं मैं तुमको
जैसे आ ग यहां पर किसी भी वेबसाइट प साइन
इन प आप जाते हो सिंपल सा मान लो तुम
विक्टिम के तरफ से अटैकर हो तुम हैकर हो
और तुमने क्या किया विक्टिम के बिहाव में
कर रहे हो अब यहां पर फॉरगॉट योर पासवर्ड
आ रहा है ठीक है फॉरगॉट योर पासवर्ड आ रहा
है यहां पर सिंपल सा फंडा है फॉरगॉट
पासवर्ड पर क्लिक
करेंगे और यहां पे एक ईमेल एड्रेस डालते
हैं तो ईमेल एड्रेस में हमने यह वाली ईमेल
आईडी डाल दी ठीक है अब यहां प सेंड रिसेट
लिंक आ रहा है मैंने इसको इंटरसेप्ट किया
मैं इसको सेंड रिसेट लिंक इंटरसेप्ट कर
रहा हूं मैं यहां पे जैसे ही मैंने
इंटरसेप्ट किया यहां पे अब आपको यहां पे
दिखेगा देखो इंडेक्स पए कंट्रोलर इ
पासवर्ड और यहां पे आपको दिख रहा होगा यह
वाली पूरी वेबसाइट जो आ रही है व
पब्लिकेशन index.php कल इ टू पासवर्ड यह
चीज आ रही है यहां पे एंड यहां पे आपको
सबमिट इज इक्वल टू समथिंग आ रहा है ये एक
रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है ठीक है भैया पासवर्ड
रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है यहां पे अब यहां पे
मैं राइट क्लिक करता हूं इसका इंटरसेप्ट
करता हूं रिस्पांस मैं यहां पे फिर से
फॉरवर्ड कर रहा हूं फॉरवर्ड कर रहा हूं
फॉरवर्ड फॉरवर्ड फॉरवर्ड फॉरवर्ड देखो अब
जैसे ही मैंने यहां पर आगे फॉरवर्ड किया
यहां पर एक रिस्पांस आ रहा है यहां पे एंड
रिस्पांस में तुम्हें दिख रहा होगा फॉरगॉट
योर
पासवर्ड एंटर द ईमेल एड्रेस यहां पे ठीक
है भैया जो ईमेल एड्रेस है वो डालिए यहां
पे एंड देन आपका पासवर्ड रिसेट जो लिंक है
वो आएगा यहां पे तो यहां पर आपको दिख रहा
होगा यह वाली पासवर्ड वनक पब्लिकेशन
इंडेक्स पासवर्ड जो कंट्रोलर है पासवर्ड
है यहां पे आपको यह
चीज यहां पर दिख रही है ठीक है जो यूआरएल
है बेसिकली वो यूआरएल आपको यहां पे दिख
रहा है यहां पे ठीक है यहां पे अब देखो
यहां पे ये देखो पासवर्ड कंट्रोलर पासवर्ड
यहां पे ये यूआरएल दिख रहा है अब अब यह
यूआरएल बेसिकली क्या होगा यह जो यूआरएल
दिख रहा है इसके अंदर एक टोकन होगा जिससे
कि ये रिकॉग्नाइज होता है कि इसी
पर्टिकुलर यूजर का ये टोकन है अब ये
कंस्ट्रक्ट कैसे होता है देखो यहां प द
विक्टिम रिसीव जेनुइन पासवर्ड रिसेट ईमेल
डायरेक्टली फ्रॉम
वेबसाइट ठीक है डायरेक्टली फ्रॉम वेबसाइट
ये जेनुइन करेगा लेकिन अगर हम होस्ट हेडर
चेंज कर दे तो हम अगर होस्ट हेडर को
मॉडिफाई कर दे तो इसका मतलब देखो द द
अटैकर ऑप्टस द विक्टिम ईमेल एड्रेस सबमिट
अ पासवर्ड रिसेट रिक्वेस्ट ऑन देयर बिहाव
व्हेन सबमिटिंग द फॉर्म दे इंटरसेप्ट द
रिजल्टिंग एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट एंड मॉडिफाई
द होस्ट सेडर सो दैट इट पॉइंट्स टू अ
डोमेन दैट दे कंट्रोल मतलब अब मैं यहां पे
क्या करूं ये जो पर्टिकुलर रिक्वेस्ट आई
है मैं यहां पे क्या कर देता हूं इसको
इंटरसेप्ट को ऑफ कर देता हूं
फिलहाल फिलहाल मैंने ऑफ किया फिलहाल मैंने
ऑफ किया ठीक है अब मैं क्या करता हूं बैक
टू लॉगइन करता हूं यहां
पे अब मैं यहां पे सिंपल से फिर से फॉरगेट
पासवर्ड प क्लिक करता
हूं अब यहां पे ईमेल एड्रे डाल देता हूं
मैं यहां पे कोई सा भी एक ईमेल एड्रेस डाल
देता हूं यहां पे ये वाली ईमेल आईडी डाल
दी मैंने ठीक है भैया ये वाली ईमेल आईडी
डाल दी अब व्हाट आई एम गोइंग टू डू रिसेट
सेंड करने के पहले इसको मैं इंटरसेप्ट
इसको मैं इंटरसेप्ट करूंगा सिंपल सा फंडा
है ना आई विल इंटरसेप्ट इट तो लेट्स लेट्स
इंटरसेप्ट इट
सेंड फॉर वट ये वाली लिंक है मैं इसको
राइट क्लिक करके सेंड टू रिपीटर प क्लिक
कर देता हूं इसको ऑफ कर देता हूं रिपीटर प
चलते हैं यहां पे रिपीटर पे आ गए यहां पे
अब यहां पे मैं गो प क्लिक करूंगा तो यह
एक रिसेट लिंक भेजता है सिंपली यहां पे
फॉरगॉट यो पासवर्ड करके यहां पे ये 200
ओके रिसेट लिंक अब मैं क्या अब मैं अब
क्या होगा जब मैं इस होस्ट को यहां पे
होस्ट हेडर इंजेक्शन यहां पे अप्लाई करूं
अब मैं क्या करता हूं होस्ट को मैं चेंज
कर देता
हूं जो यह होस्ट है इसको मैं कर देता हूं
डिफन
x.com ठीक है पहले जो हमने जब ओके किया था
जब लिंक भेजा था रिसेट वाली तो यहां पे
वनिक publications.com ही आई हुई थी
बेसिकली जो हमें रिजल्ट मिला था अ पासवर्ड
रिसेट का उसमें यहां पे वनिक पब्लिकेशन ही
आया था जो हमारी जो मेन वेबसाइट है वही
यहां पे रिफ्लेक्ट हो रही थी हम यहां मान
लो हमने de.com कर दिया ये एक अटैक
कंट्रोल डोमेन है अब हम यहां पर गो प
क्लिक करते हैं तो यह आ रहा है 404 नॉट
फाउंड क्योंकि दिस इज नॉट वल्नरेबल अगर
वल्नरेबल होगा तो यह डिफन कॉ से इंटरेक्ट
कर लेगा यानी कि अब जो लिंक जाएगी जो पहले
क्या लिंक जा रही थी पहले लिंक जा रही थी
वनक पब्लिकेशन कॉ स्ल रिसेट पासवर्ड टोकन
यह वाली लिंक जा रही थी बट जैसे ही मैंने
अपना एक हैक कंट्रोल डोमेन यूज किया मैंने
यहां पर यूज की या fix.com तो अब जो यहां
पे लिंक जाएगी यहां पे लिंक वो fix.com की
होगी ठीक है तो अब यहां पे देखिए अटैकर
वाली चीज द विक्टिम रिसीव अ जेनुइन
पासवर्ड रिसेट ईमेल डायरेक्टली फ्रॉम द
वेबसाइट ठीक है भैया क्योंकि उसी की ईमेल
आईडी दी हुई है ना तो उसी की ईमेल पे मेल
जाएगी दिस सीम्स टू कंटेन एन ऑर्डिनरी
लिंक टू रिसेट देयर पासवर्ड बट द डोमेन इन
द यूआरएल पॉइंट्स टू द अटैकर सर्वर बट जो
डोमेन होगा वो अटैकर के सर्वर पे पॉइंट
करेगा यह बात समझने वाली चीज है ठीक है तो
मैं यहां पे यह कह रहा था यह है ओरिजिन
ओरिजिनल
पासवर्ड रिसेट
लिंक ठीक है अब यहां
पर आफ्टर होस्ट हेडर
इंजेक्शन रिसेट लिंक यह कैसा
दिखेगा यह कुछ ऐसा
दिखेगा यह कुछ यहां व पब्लिकेशन कॉ ना दिख
के यहां पे दिखेगा
fix.com अब ये जाएगा इनटू
द ईमेल बॉक्स ऑफ
विक्टिम समझ में आ रहा है पहले तो ये जाता
ईमेल जाता रिसेट लिंक अब विक्टिम के ईमेल
में ये लिंक जा रही है तो विक्टिम को तो
नॉर्मल सा लिंक आया पासवर्ड रिसेट लिंक अब
लोग क्या करते हैं जनरली क्या करते हैं
उतना ध्यान नहीं देते बहुत लोग तो अब
सिंपली क्या किया अरे यार आ गई पासवर्ड
टनिंग बट इसमें
डिफ्रॉक वाली नहीं ओरिजिनल नहीं है क्यों
हमने यहां पर होस्ट हेडर इंजेक्शन किया है
हमने होस्ट को चेंज करके फ क डाला हुआ है
मान लो य पर ड कॉ वही हो यहां पर एक डबल
होस्ट करके यहां पर . कॉ डाल के देखे तो
क्या हो रहा है गो प क्लिक करें शायद यह
वल्नरेबल हो नहीं है कोई बात नहीं हम यहां
पर एक्स फॉरवर्ड होस्ट डाल के देखें तो
एक्स मतलब यहां पर होस्ट इंजेक्शन होना
चाहिए मैं यह बोल रहा हूं फॉरवार्डेड
होस्ट डाल के देखे तो
एंड देन देखते हैं क्या होता है गो पर
क्लिक कर देते हैं 302 फाउंड आ रहा है
यहां पर फॉलो रीडायरेक्शन करते
हैं 30 फाउंड 302 फाउंड ओके फॉलो
रीडायरेक्शन करते हैं अगेन 302 फाउंड ओके
कोई बात नहीं फिर से रीडायरेक्शन फॉलो कर
लेते
हैं फॉलो अरे भाई कितनी बार डायरेक्ट होगा
फॉलो व ही पब्लिकेशन आ रहा है ओके 302 आ
रहा है य फाउंड
गो पर क्लिक करते इस कमिंग 302 ठीक है कोई
बात नहीं य पर बट य पर एक्स फरड होस्ट में
डि हमने डाल के देखा एंड यहां पर हमें यह
चीज आ रही है अब हम य पर एक बार रेफरर को
भी चेंज करके देख सकते
हैं रेफरर में यहां पर व पब्लिकेशन कॉम की
जगह पर यहां पर हम डाल देते
हैं फ कॉ क लेट्स प्रेस गो 30 फंड
फॉलो तो काइंड ऑफ ये वल्नरेबल नहीं है
लेकिन यह वल्नरेबल होना चाहिए होस्ट डर
इंजेक्शन से तब जाके आपका यह पास डिसेट
पॉइजनिंग वर्क करेगा क्योंकि हम अभी जितना
कुछ कर रहे हैं वो बेसिकली किससे कर रहे
हैं वो वल्नरेबल होस्ट हेडर इंजेक्शन से
ही तो कर रहे हैं मतलब होस्ट हेडर
इंजेक्शन है तभी तो कर रहे ना है ना तो वो
चीज होनी चाहिए होस्टड इंजेक्शन तो यह चीज
आपको प्रॉपर समझ में आ रहा है ना कि क्या
हो रहा है बेसिकली कि हमने क्या किया यहां
पे होस्ट एंड इजेक्शन करके व
publication.com अब ना जाके डिफर क जाएगी
ये समझ में आ रहा है एवरीवन गेटिंग
दिस थैंक यू ब्रदर यह समझ में आ रहा
है टोकन तुम खुद नहीं क्रिएट करोगे टोकन
तो जनरेट होती है भाई यूनिक टोकन जनरेट
होता है वह तुम नहीं जनरेट
करोगे समझ में आ रहा है ना ये क्या हो रहा
है यहां पे पास थोड़ी स पॉइजनिंग
में बोलो
बोलो सभी
लोग यार बोलते ही नहीं यार बस सिंपल सा
फंडा है तो अब जैसे मुझे कैसे पता चलेगा
कि मेरे पास यह रिक्वेस्ट आई है अब यह
रिक्वेस्ट जब f.com के तरफ से जाएगी तो यह
मेरे वेबसाइट से भी तो इंटरेक्ट कर रही है
तो यह चीज आप अपने वेबसाइट के लॉग में देख
सकते आप अपने सर्वर के लॉग में देख सकते
हैं कैसे देखते हैं जैसे मेरी de.com
होस्टिंगर होस्टिंगर प होस्टेड है ठीक है
यह होस्टिंगर पे मेरी जो de.com में
होस्टेड है तो मैं कैसे देखूंगा कौन सा
यूजर मेरे से इंटरेक्ट कर रहा है कौन सी
पाथ प कर रहा है ये टोकन कैसे मुझे दिखेगी
तो मेरे पास एक स्निफर होना चाहिए या तो
आप वेबसाइट के लॉग में चेक करके आपको वहां
पर टोकन मिल जाएगा अगर यह इंटरेक्ट हुई है
तो ठीक है इंटरेक्ट हुई है तो यह क्या
होगा मेरे वेबसाइट के लॉग में मिल जाए
जाएगा जैसे मैं यहां पे वेबसाइट पे चलता
हूं
सॉरी मैं यहां मैनेज प चलता हूं कैसे लॉग
कैसे देखते हैं सब सारे होस्टिंग
प्रोवाइडर का अलग-अलग ऑप्शन होता है मैं
यहां पे परफॉर्मेंस में जाऊंगा परफॉर्मेंस
में एनालिटिक्स पे चलता हूं एनालिटिक्स पे
मैं आऊंगा यहां पे नीचे की तरफ आऊंगा तो
यहां पे मुझे एक्सेस लॉगस मिलता है मैं
एक्सेस लॉग्स पे चलता हूं एक्सेस लॉगस पे
जब मैं आऊंगा ना तो मुझे हर एक पर्टिकुलर
लॉग दिखती है जो मेरे वेबसाइट से इंटरेक्ट
कर रहे हैं यानी कोई बंदे ने किसी विक्टिम
ने मे इस डोमेन से अगर एग्जीक्यूट
इंटरेक्ट किया है f.com से तो वो यहां पे
मेरे लॉग हो जाएगा बेसिकली मेरे यहां पे
लॉग पे शो हो सकता है यहां पे आके एंड वी
वुड बी गेटिंग कि भैया देखो आईपी कौन कब
क्या टाइमिंग है वो पता चल जाएगा किस आईपी
से इंटरेक्शन हो रही है और किस पर्टिकुलर
रिक्वेस्ट किस पेज पे किस पाथ पे
रिक्वेस्ट आ रही है तो अभी जो है ये
रिक्वेस्ट आ रही है साइबर सिक्योरिटी
मास्टरी कोर्स पे एक आई हुई है पहले
डब्ल्यूपी क्रॉन पे आई है कंटेंट पे आई है
ये सारे टोटल ए टू जेड मिल जाते हैं तो
आपको यहां से यह चीज़ पता चल जाती है
डिटेल पता चल जाती है समझ में आ रहा है तो
यह आपकी वेबसाइट इसके लिए आपके पास एक
वेबसाइट एक सर्वर होना चाहिए बेसिकली बिना
उसके नहीं हो पाएगा ठीक है एक सर्वर होना
इज जरूरी अब अब बात करते हैं कि सर्वर की
जगह पे आप बर्ब का एक इन बिल्ट सर्वर यूज़
कर सकते हैं जिसको कि आप बोलते हैं यहां
पे बर्ब कोलबो र क्लाइंट तो आप बर्ब कोलबो
मेटर क्लाइंट यूज़ करके कॉपी टू
क्लिपबोर्ड करेंगे तो आपको एक सर्वर
बेसिकली यह एक सर्वर टाइप है ब सिंपल सा
फंडा है यह एक सर्वर टाइप है जिसमें आप
इंटरेक्शंस को मैप कर सकते हैं तो कॉपी टू
क्लिप बोर्ड करेंगे तो आपको एक यूआरएल मिल
जाता है यहां
पे ये यूआरएल इसको आप एज अ सर्वर
इंटरेक्शन के लिए यूज कर सकते हैं बब सूट
के अंदर में बब कोलैबोरेटर क्लाइंट का यूज
कर सकते हैं ठीक है ये काफी सादा काफी
ज्यादा यूज होता है
अ हंटर्स के तरफ से ठीक है एक बार और
रिपीट कर दीजिए सर प्लीज आप एक बार ना
रिकॉर्डिंग देखिएगा जिनको भी दिक्कत आ रही
है एक बार रिकॉर्डिंग दोबारा देखिएगा आपको
समझ में आ जाएगा 110 पर आपको समझ में आएगा
इट्स माय गारंटी और हमारे
सारे अपडेट्स इस पे आते हैं डेनिक साइबर
सिक्योरिटी के ठीक है अब देखो यह तो समझ
में आ गया
आपको यह पासवर्ड इ व्हेन इफ द विक्टिम
क्लिक्स दिस लिंक्स ठीक है द पासवर्ड
रिसेट टोकन विल बी डिलीवर्ड टू द अटैकर
सर्वर्स अटैकर के सर्वर के पास डिलीवर हो
जाएगा स्निफर है तो वहां पे भी वो डिलीवर
हो जाएगा स्निफिंग अगर कर रहा है तो डकर
कैन नाउ विजिट द रियल यूआरएल अब मेरे पास
टोकन आ चुका है मेरे पास मेरे को टोकन मिल
चुका है पासवर्ड रि सेट टोकन तो अब एज एन
अटैकर मैं क्या करूंगा मेरे पास
टोकन आ चुका
भैया यह वाला टोकन आ चुका ठीक है अब मैं
क्या करूंगा सेम यूआरएल में जाऊंगा यहां
पे सेम यूआरएल जो हमारा था जो ओरिजिनल
यूआरएल इस टोकन को डालूंगा और इस लिंक को
विजिट कर लूंगा विजिट करते ही पासवर्ड
रिसेट का मेरे पास एक अ पासवर्ड रिसेट
लिंक प चला जाऊंगा वहां पे एक पॉपअप आ
जाएगा पासवर्ड रिसेट करने का बॉक्स आ
जाएगा और वहां पे मैं अपना पासवर्ड जो है
वो रिसेट कर पाऊंगा एंड पासवर्ड रिसेट हो
जाएगी सिंपल और वो मैंने अकाउंट किसका
रिसेट कर दिया पासवर्ड विक्टिम का यानी कि
मैंने उसका अकाउंट टेक ओवर कर लिया मैं
उसके अकाउंट में लॉग इन कर सकता हूं एंड
वहां पर फिर अब अकाउंट टेकओवर लेबिलिटी हो
गई तो हमने बेसिकली क्या किया यहां पे
आपको अभी इसका आईडिया शायद नहीं लग रहा हो
बट मैं आपको बताता हूं तब आपको समझ में आ
जाएगा हमने बेसिकली क्या किया वी
चेंज होस्ट हेडर
इंजेक्शन इंजेक्शन टू अकाउंट
टेकओवर लेबिलिटी
अकाउंट टेकओवर में हमने इसको कर दिया ठीक
है फिर हमने यानी कि हमने होस्ट हेडर से
क्याक किया देखिए होस्ट ड इंजेक्शन से
हमने क्या क्या किया आपको
देखो होस्ट डा इंजेक्शन
से
हमने ओपन रीडायरेक्शन
किया बहुत शानदार चीज है भाई समझ में नहीं
आ रही है तो भी दोबारा दोबारा देखो वीडियो
देखो समझ में आएगी रिकॉर्डिंग देखो समझ
में आएगी ओपन डायरेक्शन किया मुझे पता है
कुछ लोगों के दिमाग में यह नहीं आ रहा
होगा कुछ लोगों के आज अभी जो क्लास चल रही
है समझ में नहीं आ रहा होगा क्योंकि ऊपर
से जा रहा होगा बट स्टिल इट्स वर्थ टू वच
रिकॉर्डिंग रिपीट करिएगा रिकॉर्डिंग
रिकॉर्डिंग को जितनी बार आप रिपीट करेंगे
मैं आपको यकीन के साथ कह सकता हूं आपको
अच्छे से समझ में आ जाएगा यह चीज जो मैं
आपको बता रहा हूं क्योंकि पहली बार में
शायद आपको समझ में ना आए कई बार होता है
कि समझ में नहीं आती ये चीजें बट दूसरी
बार रिपीट करते हैं मल्टीपल टाइम्स तो
आपको समझ में आ जाएगी पहली हमने ओपन
डायरेक्शन देखी फिर
हमने वेब कैश पॉइजनिंग
करा फिर हमने वी आर ओपनिंग द
लैब तो यह लैब ओपन
होगी नहीं वॉइस तो सही है अब यहां पर लॉग
इन प जाते
हैं लॉगिन प गए यहां पे अब यहां पर हम
लॉगिन प आते हैं विनर पीटर पे तो यहां पर
एक फॉरगेट पासवर्ड का आपको यहां पर एक पाथ
एक ऑप्शन दिख रहा है दिख रहा है आपको ठीक
है फॉरगेट पासवर्ड का तो व्हाट वी आर
गोइंग टू डू यहां पर
विनर पीटर से लॉग इनन कर सकते हैं तो एक
काम करते हैं
विनर एंड पीटर ये लॉगइन करते एक
बार मैंने जैसे ही लॉगइन किया यहां पे आ
रहा है यूजर नेम विनर और ईमेल आईडी जो है
आपको यहां पे यह दिख रही है यह ईमेल आईडी
हमारी विनर @ एक्सप्लोइट फलाना डिकाना ठीक
है चलिए अच्छी बात है मैं यहां पे लॉग आउट
कर देता
हूं लॉगइन प जाता
हूं अब यहां पे फॉरगेट पासवर्ड का एक
ऑप्शन आ रहा है तो मैं क्या करता हूं
फॉरगेट पासवर्ड प जाता हूं यहां पे
एसटीडीपी हिस्ट्री में आते हैं यहां पे
एसटीडीपी हिस्ट्री में यहां पर एटीटीपी
हिस्ट्री में आएंगे तो यहां पे
0606 वाली जो हमारी चीज है यह देखिए यहां
यहां पे एक फॉरगॉट पासवर्ड का लिंक आ रहा
है यहां पे एक फॉरगॉट पासवर्ड का एक हमारा
क्वेरी जो है व आया हुआ है यहां पे आप सब
देख सकते हैं य
पे लाइव चल रही है ना
भाई
इ लाइव ऑन गोइंग
गाइस लाइव में कोई प्रॉब्लम आ रही है
क्या मुझे
बता ओके सही है सही है लाइव इज
गुड ओके लाइ इज गुड ओके अभी ठीक है लाइव
अभी सही है अभी सही है ठीक है चलिए अभी
सही है अभी सही है ओके अब देखिए यहां
पे तो यहां पे पासवर्ड रिसेट का एक पेज
आया जैसे मैंने पासवर्ड रिसेट पे क्लिक
किया वी गॉट द रिक्वेस्ट हियर अ यहां पे
फॉरगॉट पासवर्ड का ठीक है फॉरगॉट पासवर्ड
का एक रिक्वेस्ट यहां पे हमारे पास सामने
आया है मैं यहां पे ठीक है ना मैं इसको
राइट क्लिक करके सेंड टू रिपीटर कर देता
हूं चलिए अच्छी बात है अब यहां पे एंटर
योर यूजर नेम और ईमेल तो यूजर नेम मैं
डालता हूं विनर मैं यूजर नेम डाल देता हूं
यहां पे यहां पे सबमिट मैं क्लिक करूंगा
सबमिट करूंगा यहां पे तो यहां पे आ रहा है
प्लीज चेक योर ईमेल फॉर अ रिसेट पासवर्ड
लिंक ठीक है एक रिसेट पासवर्ड लिंक आई
होगी ईमेल तो ईमेल कैसे चेक होगा तो गो टू
एक्सप्लोइट
सर्वर नीचे आएंगे ईमेल क्लाइंट जो है इसको
ओपन कर लेंगे जैसे ही ईमेल क्लाइंट ओपन
करेंगे हमें यहां पर एक ईमेल आई है विनर
वाली जो हमें मेल है वहां हमें आई है
फ्रॉम कहां से नो रिप्लाई
सॉरी नो रिप्लाई आया य प अब यहां पर हमें
एक पासवर्ड रिसेट प्लीज फॉलो द लिंक बिलो
टू रिसेट योर पासवर्ड तो यह पासवर्ड रिसेट
करने का एक लिंक आया मैं इस पर क्लिक करता
हूं जैसे क्लिक करूंगा न्यू पासवर्ड डालने
का यहां पर आएगा तो मैं यहां पर न्यू
पासवर्ड डाल देता हूं ठीक है तो मैं क्या
डालता हूं पासवर्ड में ए बी सी
थ 45 ठीक है ए बी सी ट 345 ये मैंने करके
यहां पर सबमिट कर दिया सबमिट किया पासवर्ड
चेंज हो गई एटीपी हिस्ट्री में चलते हैं
यहां पे एसटीडीपी हिस्ट्री में जब आप
जाएंगे गाइस तो आपको यहां पे दिखेगा नीचे
प यहां पे कि फॉरगॉट पासवर्ड वाली जो चीज
थी या आ गई थी और यहां पे आपको एक यूआरएल
मिलेगी फॉरगॉट पासवर्ड टेंपररी यहां पे
पासवर्ड टोकन एक टेंपररी पासवर्ड टोकन आ
रहा है मैं राइट क्लिक करके इसको भी
रिपीटर को भेज देता हूं ठीक है यहां पे
आपको दिख रहा होगा रिपीटर पे आते हैं तो
यहां पे एक टेंपररी पासवर्ड रिसेट टोकन आ
रहा है ये वाली ये देखा ये टोकन आ रहा है
ओके अब मैं क्या करता हूं इसको गो पे
क्लिक करता हूं जैसे ही मैं गो पे क्लिक
करूंगा जीरो इनवैलिड टोकन आ रहा है दिस इज
कमिंग इनवैलिड टोकन क्यों भैया ऐसा क्यों
आ रहा है तो चलिए प्रॉक्सी पे चलते हैं
यहां
पे यह वाली रिक्वेस्ट को करते हैं सेंड टू
रिपीटर रिपीटर चलते हैं यहां पे गो पे
क्लिक कर देते हैं एंड यहां पे अभी ये
इनवैलिड टोकन आ रहा है ठीक है क्योंकि
हमने क्या किया यह हमारी प्रीवियस
रिक्वेस्ट की थी तो हमने यहां पे क्या
किया सिंपल सा एक पासवर्ड रिसेट किया एंड
हमें एक मेल आया हुआ है जब हम ईमेल
क्लाइंट पर जाते हैं यहां पर तो हम इसको
जब रीलोड करते हैं यहां पर यहां पर मैं
रिड कर रहा हूं यहां प तो हम एक मेल आया
है पासवर्ड रिसेट का एंड यहां पर यह वाली
रिसेट लिंक आई हुई है मुझे और इसमें एक
टोकन आया है टीव बी3 करके जो कि यहां पर
आपको टोकन दिख रहा टीव बी3 करके य टोकन
दिख रहा है ओके अब मुझे क्या करना है लैब
के
अकॉर्डिंग टू सॉल्व द ल लॉगइन टू कार्लस
अकाउंट तो आपका क्या करना है हमें देखो य
टू गो टू दसप ओपन द ईमेल क्लाइंट
रिक्वेस्ट पासवर्ड रिसेट लिंक अब यहां पे
फॉर टेंपररी अब यूआरएल एक टेंप फॉरगेट
पासवर्ड टोकन यहां पे आ रही है यहां पे
बॉब शूट में आप जाएंगे तो फॉरगेट पासवर्ड
रिक्वेस्ट को देखेंगे तो एक ट्रिगर द
पासवर्ड रिसेट ईमेल यहां पे आई होगी ठीक
है ना फॉरगेट पासवर्ड वाली ईमेल पे तो
चलिए यहां पे बब शूट पे चलते हैं यहां पे
प्रॉक्सी पे चलते हैं एंड यहां पे फॉरगेट
पासवर्ड वाली जो आई ई यहां पे ये पासवर्ड
रिसेट लिंक है यहां पे जो कि जनरेट हुई है
चलिए अच्छी बात है दिस कंटेंस यूजर नेम
हुज पासवर्ड इज बीइंग रिसेट बाय ए बॉडी
पैरामीटर सेंड दिस टू बप रिपीटर ठीक है
भैया तो हमने रिपीटर को भेज दिया इन
रिपीटर र्ट यू कैन चेंज द होस्ट हेडर टू
एन आर्बिट वैल्यू एंड स्टिल सक्सेसफुली
ट्रिगर पासवर्ड सेट तो समझ में आ रहा
सिंपल सा फंडा तो मैं यहां पर बप रिपीटर
में चल जाता हूं यहां
पर मैं एक काम करता हूं मैं फिर से इसको
डिलीट कर देता हूं क्लियर हिस्ट्री अगेन
मैं यहां पर आ जाता हूं अपने इस वाली पेज
पर यहां पर चलते माय अकाउंट पर चलते हैं
अगेन मैं फॉरगॉट पासवर्ड पर क्लिक करता
हूं अगेन दोबारा यहां पर मुझे एक फॉरगॉट
पासवर्ड का एक यूआरएल आ चुका है ठीक है
मैं यहां पर अगेन विनर डालता हूं एंड यहां
पर मैं सबमिट करता हूं जैसे ही मैंने
सबमिट किया पासवर्ड रिट लिंक जा चुका है
जैसे मैंने सबमिट किया आपको यहां पर
दिखेगा यह फॉरगॉट पासवर्ड वाली जो चीज है
व हुई है यहां
पर एक्सप्लोइट सवर पर चलते
हैं ठीक है ट टू एक्सप्लोइट सर्वर यहां
एक्सट सवर प आके अब यहां पर हम ईमेल
क्लाइंट ओपन कर लेते
हैं ईमेल क्लाइंट ओपन करेंगे तो हमारे पास
एक और मेल आई होगी अभी जो मेल आई है बाद
में यह लेटेस्ट मेल यह वाली है तो हमारे
पास एक यह मेल आ गई है ठीक है अब हम
एसटीडीपी हिस्ट्री पर चलेंगे जब यहां
पे यहां पर तो अब हम यह वाली मेल आ गई
पासवर्ड रिसेट मेल अब देखो क्या
है गो टू एक स्प सवे एंड ओपन द ईमेल
क्लाइंट ऑब्जर्व दैट यू हैव रिसीवड एन
ईमेल कंटेनिंग लिड टू अ पासवर्ड लिंक ठीक
है नोटिस द यूआरएल कंटेंस द क्वेरी
पैरामीटर टेंप फॉरगॉट पासवर्ड टोकन तो हम
यहां पे जब आएंगे यहां पे तो यहां पे एक
लिंक आई जो है ये क्वेरी पैरामीटर क्या है
ये टेंप फॉरगॉट पासवर्ड टोकन ठीक है टेंप
फॉरगॉट पासवर्ड टोकन ये वाली चीज हमें आई
हुई है एक क्वेरी आई हुई है ठीक है अब इन
बप स्टडी द हिस्ट्री नोटिस दैट द पोस्ट
फॉरगॉट पासवर्ड रिसेंट इ यूज टू ट्रिगर द
पासवर्ड दिस कंटेंस द यूजर नेम अब ये
फॉरगॉट पासवर्ड जो है यह वाली जो हमारा
फॉरगेट पासवर्ड जो हमारा यह वाला बेसिकली
पेज है तो आप देख सकते हैं इसको मैं राइट
क्लिक करके सेंड टू रिपीटर करता हूं यहां
प रिपीटर प आते हैं यहां प तो इसमें यहां
पर जब आप आएंगे यहां पर इस वाले में तो
यहां पर देखिए एक चीज कहां गई कहां गई
कहां गई कहां गई कहां गई कहां
गई यह फॉरगॉट पासवर्ड आर आ रही है यहां
पे गो पर क्लिक करते हैं यहां पर जैसे ही
मैंने गो पर क्लिक किया यहां पर यहां पर आ
गया फॉरगॉट पासवर्ड वाला जो चीज है यहां
पर नीचे आते हैं यहां
पर एंड वी विल सी नीचे आ जाओ नीचे आ जाओ
नीचे आ जाओ नीचे आ जाओ नीचे आ जाओ नीचे आ
जाओ नीचे आ जाओ माय अकाउंट यूजर
नेम यहां पर ी डब्लू आई ई एन ओके यहां
कार्लोस ठीक
है ठीक है तो ये एक फॉरगॉट पासवर्ड लिंक
था अब यहां पे क्या करते हैं अब यहां पे
क्या करना है इन बप रिपीटर ऑब्जर्व दैट यू
कैन चेंज द होस्ट हेडर टू एन आर्बिट्री
वैल्यू तो अब हम बब रिटर पे चलते हैं यहां
पे होस्ट डर को हम एक आर्बिट्री वैल्यू पे
डाल देते हैं कोई सा भी एक रैंडम वैल्यू
डाल देते हैं मैंने यहां पे डाल दिया
bing.com bing.com यहां पे डाल दिया एंड
गो पे क्लिक किया जैसे ही मैंने गो पे
क्लिक किया अब भी हम पासवर्ड रिसेट जनरेट
कर पा रहे हैं अभी हमारा ये 200 होके आ
रहा है और पासवर्ड रिसेट पेज जो है वो
जनरेट हो रही है अभी भी इसका मतलब ये है
कि दिस इज इफेक्टेड ठीक है दिस कंटेंस द
यूजर नेम ठीक है ट्र गो बैक टू द ईमेल सवा
एंड लुक फॉर द न्यू ईमेल चलिए अब एक न्यू
ईमेल प न्यू ईमेल के लिए लुक डाउन करते
हैं तो एक्सपर्ट स प चलते हैं इसको रीलोड
कर लेते
हैं जैसे ही हम रीलोड करेंगे लेट्स
सी लेट्स
रीलोड यहां पे हमने bing.com किया ना फ
फॉरगेट पासवर्ड
पे यह फॉरगेट पासवर्ड जो हुई है यहां पे
सेंड टू रिपीटर रिपीटर प चलते हैं यहां पे
यहां पे हम कर देते हैं bing.com एंड यहां
पे हम गो पे क्लिक कर देते हैं हां जी तो
मैंने जैसे ही गो पे क्लिक किया यहां पे
देखिए ये किसके लिए है यूजर नेम विनर के
लिए है और यहां पे मैंने bing.com डाला
यहां पे ओ किया अब मैं यहां पे चलता हूं
अपने ईमेल क्लाइंट पे रीलोड करता हूं अब
जैसे ही मैंने रीलोड किया अब देखो मेरे को
एक और मेल आई है इसको ध्यान देखो हां सॉरी
अ ये वाली चीज थी पोस्ट वाली चीज थी
रिक्वेस्ट थी बिल्कुल सही है पोस्ट वाली
रिक्वेस्ट थी हमने क्या किया था गलत से
यहां पे क्या गेट वाली फॉरगॉट पासवर्ड ले
ली थी बट एक्चुअली ये पोस्ट वाली
रिक्वेस्ट थी तो हमने यहां पे रिपीटर पे आ
गए अब हम यहां पे विनर के लिए यहां पे ये
चीज कर रहे हैं हमने bing.com होस्ट हेडर
इंजेक्शन किया अब जैसे bing.com किया हमें
एक पासवर्ड रिसेट लिंक वापस से आई एंड दिस
टाइम वी गॉट अ पास पा डिसेंट लिंक यहां पे
bing.com फॉरगॉट पासवर्ड हमें अब प्रीवियस
जो हमारा ओरिजिनल जो वेबसाइट था ना यूआरएल
था वो नहीं है अब अब यहां पे एक फोर्जड एक
जो हमारा एटीटीपी बेसिकली वेबसाइट है
फोर्जड एक डोमेन उससे हमें पासवर्ड रिट
लिंक आई है bing.com से जो कि एक अटैकर का
डोमेन है लेट्स सपोज या f.com बोल लो या
कुछ कुछ भी बोल लो जो अटैकर कंट्रोल डोमेन
है और इसमें हमें एक टोकन मिला है अब इस
टोकन को हम यहां से कॉपी कर लेते
हैं इस टोकन को हमने कॉपी किया और इसको हम
कहीं पे लिख देते
हैं
सो
टोकन
कैप्चरड तो यह टोकन हमें मिला ठीक है तो
बढ़िया यह टोकन हमें मिल गया अब क्या कर
देते हैं नोटिस द यूआरएल होस्ट इंस्टेड ऑफ
यूजुअल डोमेन नोटिस द यूआरएल इन द ईमेल
डोमेन कंटेंस योर आर्बिट्री होस्ट डोमेन
यानी जो अटैकर का डोमेन है वो है इन द बप
रिपीटर चेंज द होस्ट हेडर टू योर
एक्सप्लोइट सर्वस डोमेन नेम एंड द चेंज द
यूजर नेम टू कार्लोस ठीक है तो अब क्या
करना है भैया कि एक बप रिपीटर में जाके
यहां पे होस्ट हेडर को चेंज करना है
एक्सप्लोइट सर्वर के डोमेन नेम से ठीक है
तो हम चलते हैं एक्सप्लोइट सवर पे एंड य
इसका जो डोमेन है यह वाली इससे चेंज कर
देते
हैं एक्सप्लोइट सर्वर के लिए अब हम क्या
करते हैं होस्ट को हम एक्सप्लोइट सर्वर का
डोमेन डाल देते
हैं डलिया और यूजर नेम को हम कार्लोस कर
देते हैं कार्लोस जो हमें करना था तो
कार्लोस हमने कर दिया अब हम इसको यहां पर
क्या कर देते हैं गो पे क्लिक करते हैं
जैसे ही हमने गो पे क्लिक किया 200 ओके आ
रहा है यहां पे अब यहां पे कार्लोस आ रहा
है क्या कहीं पे अभी तो फिलहाल नहीं आ रहा
बट हमने यहां प गो पे क्लिक किया नाउ
लेट्स डू वन थिंग व्हाट वी आर गोइंग टू डू
लेट्स रीलोड दिस पेज लेट्स रीलोड रीलोड
किया अभी कुछ नहीं आया यहां पर नहीं कुछ
आया बट हम एसटीडीपी हिस्ट्री में चलते हैं
प्रॉक्सी में चलते हैं एसटीडीपी हिस्ट्री
में चलते हैं एसटीडी हिस्ट्री में जब
जाओगे नीचे आओगे नीचे आओगे नीचे आओगे तो
तुम्हें एक चीज यहां पर देखने को
मिलेगी लेट्स सी इट इज शोइंग और
नॉट लेट्स सी लेट्स सी लेट्स
सी फॉरगेट पासवर्ड यह वाली नहीं थी यह
वाली भी नहीं होगी यह वाली भी नहीं होगी अ
वी आर नॉट गेटिंग
हियर
फॉरगेट पासवर्ड फॉरगेट पासवर्ड यह वाली
नहीं है हमारी पास यह वाली यूआरएल नहीं है
यह यूआरएल नहीं
है यह पर्टिकुलर यूआरएल तो नहीं है तो एक
काम करते हैं एक बार रिपीटर पर चलते हैं
अगेन अगेन मैं इसको गो पर क्लिक कर देता
हूं ओके यहां पर हमने एक्सप्लोइट सवर की
आईडी डाली है जीरो ए बी सी सब कुछ सही है
ना
हां सही है रीलोड करते हैं
इसको
[संगीत]
अ कुछ नहीं आ यहां गो टू द एक्सपर्ट स एंड
ओपन द अच्छा तो ये जो हमने कर दिया ये
हमने भेजा एक बार ठीक है वी सेंट हियर
हमने दो बार वैसे भेज दिया है तो अब हमें
क्या करना है इसको चेक करना है लॉग में तो
एक्सप्लोइट सवर पे जब हम आएंगे यहां पे
यहां प एक्सप्लोइट सवर अगेन चलते य एक्सट
स प ठीक
है यहां प एक्सट स चलते हैं य नीचे आते
हैं एक्सेस लॉक पर क्लिक करते हैं लेट्स
क्लिक ऑन एक्सेस लॉक जैसे ही हम एक्सेस
लॉक पर क्लिक करेंगे हमें यहां पर एक
रिक्वेस्ट मिलेगी देखो कौन सी रिक्वेस्ट
है यहां पर देखते हैं लेट्स स्क्रॉल डाउन
स्क्रोल डाउन यह रहा फॉरगेट पासवर्ड टेंप
फॉरगेट पासवर्ड टोकन यहां पर एक टोकन मिल
रहा है ठीक है हमें एक रिक्वेस्ट मिल रही
है यहां पर जिसमें कि एक फॉरगेट पासवर्ड
का एक टोकन जनरेट होके मिला है यह वाली
टोकन ठीक है तो अब क्या यहां पे करना
है पैरामीटर कंटेनिंग कार्लोस पासवर्ड
रिसेट टोकन मेक ए नोट ऑफ दिस टोकन गो टू द
ईमेल क्लाइंट एंड कॉपी द जेनुइन पासवर्ड
रिसेट यूआरएल फ्रॉम योर फर्स्ट ईमेल ठीक
है फर्स्ट ईमेल से हमें लेना है विजिट दिस
यूआरएल इन द ब्राउजर बट रिप्लेस योर टोकन
विद द वन विद द कार्लोस टोकन अब चलिए यहां
पे एक कार्लोस का टोकन हमें मिला है यूजर
का तो अब हम क्या करते हैं पहले वाले जो
हमारी पास आई हुई थी ना अ सिंपल पहली वाली
जो यूआरएल थी ओरिजिनल वाली यूआरएल ठीक है
उस परे हम चलते हैं तो य ओरिजिनल वाली जो
यूआरएल थी ये वाली यूआरएल हमारे पास आई
हुई थी तो हम इसको कॉपी कर लेते हैं और
इसको चल देते हैं यहां पे पेस्ट कर देते
हैं बट इस टोकन में इस टोकन के जगह प हम
कार्लोस वाली जो टोकन थी यूजर की ये टोकन
डालेंगे तो कौन सा टोकन है भाई देख लेते
हैं एक बार बाद में कौन आया था 159 में ये
आया था और 10 में ये आया था ये है लेटेस्ट
वाला 10 में ये आता था तो ये है लेटेस्ट
वाला तो ये वाली टोकन को मैं यहां पे कॉपी
करता हूं
लेटस कॉपी
इट कॉपी किया हमने और यहां पर टोकन को डाल
दिया हमने और अब हम एंटर करते हैं लेट्स
सी व्ट इ हैपनिंग अब यहां पर न्यू पासवर्ड
क्रिएट करने का रहा है तो न्यू पासवर्ड
मैं क्रिएट कर देता हूं ए बी
सी ए बी सी थ एंड ए बी सी टूथ एंड यहां पर
सबमिट करते हैं लेट्स सी व्ट इज हैपनिंग
सबमिट किया हमने पासवर्ड हो गया अब मैं
अकाउंट में लॉगइन करता हूं माय अकाउंट पर
चलता हूं मैं यहां पर यूजर डालता हूं
कार्लोस कार्लोस एंड य पासवर्ड देता हूं ए
बी सी 12 23 जो हमने कार्लोस के लिए सेट
किया था मैं लॉगइन करूंगा अगर मैं लॉगिन
हो गया तो
दैट्ची स्टेप्स तो किए बट बहुत ही सिंपल
सा पहले हमने सिंपल सा एक पासवर्ड रिसेट
लिंक भेजा जो कि हमारा यह वाला लिंक था यह
वाला एक लिंक आ आया पासवर्ड रिसेट लिंक अब
हमने वहां पे होस्ट हेडर इंजेक्शन किया
bing.com वहां पे डाला होस्ट हेडर के अंदर
में हमने जो बब शूट में यहां प डाला होस्ट
हेडर में bing.com किया एंड इसके लिए एक
पासवर्ड रिसेट लिंक मंगवाया जिसमें
bing.com आया जहां पे हमें ये एक अलग
डिफरेंट टोकन मिला ठीक है बस एज सिंपल एज
दैट अब हमने क्या किया यहां पे जब हमने
bing.com करके देखा तो अब हम bing.com को
हमने यहां पे रिप्लेस किया bing.com को
हमने किससे रिप्लेस किया एक्सप्लोइट सर्वर
के यूआरएल से रिप्लेस किया और हमारे यूजर
को कार्लोस से रिप्लेस किया जिसको हम चेंज
करने वाले थे और फिर हमने इस रिक्वेस्ट को
सेंड किया अब हमने इस रिक्वेस्ट को
एक्सप्लोइट सर्वर के एक्सेस लॉग में जो आप
एक्सप्लॉयड सर्वर पे जब आप जाते हो
बेसिकली यहां पे एक्सेस लॉक्स पे जब जाते
हो तो यहां पे जितने भी तरह के जो भी
रिक्वेस्ट आती है वो सब यहां पे आप एक्सेस
कर सकते हैं यहां इसके जगह पे आपका अपना
सर्वर हो सकता है तो हमने जब इस रिक्वेस्ट
हिस्ट्री को देखा तो हमें यहां पे एक
पासवर्ड फॉरगेट पासवर्ड का एक टेंपररी
टोकन आया जो कि यूजर कार्लोस के लिए हमने
भेजा था रिक्वेस्ट ठीक है तो हमें दो
रिक्वेस्ट आई थी जो लेटेस्ट रिक्वेस्ट थी
हमने उसको देखा था 1510 जो आया था तो
इसमें हमें एक टोकन मिला हुआ था तो हमने
इस टोकन को सिंपली कॉपी कर लिया और हमने
जो हमारा ओरिजिनल यूआरएल था पासवर्ड रिसेट
लि वाली जो यूआरएल थी उसको कॉपी किया यहां
पे और उसमें हमने वो वाली जो चीज थी डाल
दी हमने सिंपल इसको कॉपी
किया यहां हमने डाला और यहां पे हमने टोकन
वैल्यू को इसको चेंज करके जो ओरिजिनल विनर
के लिए थी थी हमने इस टोकन से रिप्लेस कर
दिया जो हमें एक टोकन मिला हुआ था जो
मैंने आपको बताया ही था कि स्निफर अगर है
तो उसे स्निफ कर सकते हो या सर्वर है वहां
पे टोकन आपको मिल जाएगा वहां टोकन आपको
वैल्यू पता चल जाए रही उस टोकन को यहां
रिप्लेस कर दीजिए यानी कि हमने कार्लोस
वाली जो यूजर की टोकन थी यहां रिप्लेस कर
दिया और हमने जैसे ही एंटर किया हमें
सिंपली यहां पे न्यू पासवर्ड का ऑप्शन
पहले हमने कर दिया था इसलिए इनवैलिड टोकन
अब बता रहा है क्योंकि ये एक बार यूज हो
चुका है तो हमने यहां पे लैब को सॉल्व कर
लिया
दैट्ची मुझे बताइए किन लोगों को समझ में आ
गया यह चीज बता दीजिए मुझे जल्दी जल्दी
बताइए एवरीवन लेट मी नो
फास्ट जल्दी बता दए जल्दी जल्दी जल्दी समझ
में आया गाइस एवरी
बडी
हा चलिए जिनको समझ में नहीं आया डोंट वरी
भाई टेंशन नहीं लेना है ठीक है ना टेंशन
नहीं लेना है दोबारा रिपीट कीजिएगा वीडियो
को वीडियो को दोबारा देखिएगा थोड़ा आराम
आराम से रिलैक्स होके लिखते चलिए चीजों को
आपको समझ में आ जाएगा 100% ठीक है थोड़ा
कन्फ्यूज हो गया मैं समझ रहा हूं बट ये
आपको दोबारा जब आप देखोगे ना वीडियो को
रिपीट मारोगे तो 110
समझ में आ जाएगा बध ऋषि सर मुझे समझ नहीं
आया कोई बात नहीं वीडियो को दोबारा देखिए
समझ में आ जाएगा 110 पर ठीक है गॉट इट
100% समझ में आ जाएगा बस सिंपल सा फंडा
हमने कुछ किया ही नहीं हमने एक्चुअल में
कुछ नहीं किया अगर देखा जाए पहला स्टेप
में हमने क्या किया पासवर्ड
रिसेट लिंक जनरेट
करा दूसरे स्टेप में होस्ट हेडर इंजेक्शन
करा एंड रिप्लेस होस्ट फ्रॉम रियल होस्ट
टू बिंग कॉम ठीक है तीसरे स्टेप में
रिप्लेस बंगड
कॉम टू एक्सप्लोइट सर्वर
यूआरएल ठीक है चौथे स्टेप में हमने क्या
किया
मॉनिटर मॉनिटर्ड द एक्सेस लॉग ऑफ
एक्सप्लोइट सर्वर जो आपका खुद का भी सर्वर
हो सकता है एक्सप्लोइट
सर्वर रिप्लेस बंगड टू एक्सप्लोइट यूआरएल
एंड यूजर टू कार्लोस मॉनिटर द एक्सप्लोइट
लॉ अब हमने मॉनिटर किया एक्सप्लोइट सर्वर
को ठीक है तो पांचवें
में गॉट
अ
पासवर्ड रिसेट टोकन ऑफ कार्लोस
यूजर कार्लोस यूजर ठीक है छठे स्टेप में
हमने क्या
किया टूक
द ओरिजिनल
फर्स्ट पासवर्ड रिसेट लिंक एंड
रिप्लेस द टोकन फ्रॉम दैट रिप्लेस द
टोकन फ्रॉम द
टोकन ऑफ कार्लोस दैट वी गट फ्रॉम एक्सेस
लॉग
सक्सेसफुली रिसेट द पासवर्ड फॉर यूजर
कार्लोस
बस यही तो किया यही जो स्टेप्स थे यही
स्टेप्स थे सिंपल हमने यही तो किया
प्रैक्टिकली अब क्लियर थोड़ा हुआ क्या
हमने किया सीधा पासवर्ड रिसेट लिंक जनरेट
किया सबसे पहले जो कि विनर यूजर की
फॉर विनर
यूजर उसके बाद होस्ट एने इजेक्शन किया और
होस्ट को bing.com किया और देखा कि हम फिर
भी पासवर्ड रिसेट लिंक जनरेट कर पा रहे
हैं भाई होस्ट को bing.com किया अच्छा यह
वीडियो ऐड चल गई है मैं थोड़ा देर के लिए
वेट करता
हूं हमने होस्ट को बंगड क्यों किया फिर भी
पासवर्ड रिसेट लिंक जनरेट कर पा रहे है अब
हमने bing.com को जो हमारा एक्सप्लोइट
सर्वर का यूआरएल था उससे जनरेट कर दिया और
कार उससे चेंज कर दिया और यूजर को का
कार्लोस में कार्लोस कर दिया विनर की जगह
पे इंस्टेड
ऑफ
विनर अब हमने एक्सेस लॉग मॉनिटर किया
एक्सप्लॉयड सर्वर का वहां पे एक पासवर्ड
रिसेट टोकन आया कार्लोस यूजर का ठीक है अब
हमने क्या किया ओरिजिनल पासवर्ड रिसेट
लिंक लिया और उसमें का कार्लोस वाला जो
पासवर्ड टोकन था उसको डाल दिया जो पहले
विनर का टोकन था उसको रिप्लेस कर दिया
कार्लोस वाले टोकन से और उसके बाद यूआरएल
को विजिट किया हमें एक पॉपअप आ गया कि भाई
यहां पे पासवर्ड चेंज कीजिए पासवर्ड चेंज
किया वो पासवर्ड चेंज हुआ किसके लिए
कार्लो यूजर के लिए अब हम कार्लोस के
अकाउंट में लॉग इन कर चुके
हैं ठीक
है स्क्रीन को छोटा कर
दू यह
रहा अब समझ में आ गया गट
इट अब तो समझ में आया
भाई छोटा कर दिया स्क्रीन अब स्क्रीनशॉट
ले
लो
ये वाली स्क्रीनशॉट ले
लो य और छोटा कर देता हूं मैं
थोड़ा ताकि तुम एक बार में ही ले लो सारे
स्क्रीनशॉट हां
जी आ गया सर सर मेरे को एक बग मिला था पर
वह p5 में चला गया आपकी बग बाउंट
सीरीज से धीरे-धीरे पीव भी आ जाएगा थैंक
यू सर मैं आपको टैग करूंगा
पढ़ रहा हूं लैब भी सॉल्व कर र हूं बट डिड
नॉट गेट एनीथिंग जब मैंने शुरू किया था तो
मुझे भाई कम से कम मुझे छ महीने तक सात आ
महीने तक कुछ नहीं मिला था तो अभी तो आपका
कुछ नहीं हुआ चार महीने हुआ है अभी तो
बहुत बचा हुआ है सर ऐसे ही पूरा स्टेप लिख
के पीडीएफ दे दीजिए सारे क्लास का ताकि
नोट्स देख के प्रैक्टिस करने का आसानी हो
नोट्स तो आपको खुद ही बनाने पड़ेंगे नोट्स
मैं नहीं बना सकता यार इतना टाइम नहीं हो
पाता है नोट्स आई कैन क्रिएट मैं यहां पे
सारे स्टेप्स लिख दे रहा हूं आप लोग
स्क्रीनशॉट ले लेके नोट्स बना सकते हैं
इसका स्क्रीनशॉट ले लिया कीजिए और इसके
नोट्स बना लिया कीजिए ठीक
है विनय अभी मैं फाइनल ईयर में हूं साइबर
सिक्योरिटी कंपनीज नहीं आ रही है
प्लेसमेंट कैसे लू
नहीं आती यर टू यर थी कॉलेजेस में सिटीज
के कॉलेज में बहुत मुश्किल सेही आती है तो
वहां प्लेसमेंट भी नहीं होती है तो आप
डायरेक्ट लिंकन से यह चीज अप्लाई करो
अप्रोच करो आपकी जॉब लग सकती
है ठीक
है ओके ओके ठीक है ठीक है नि शर्क मैं
देखूंगा मैसेज आपका कहां पे किया आपने
चलिए तो आई होप आपको समझ में आ गया होगा
एंड एक्सएसएस का पार्ट हमने देख ही लिया
था कि किस तरीके से हमने एक्सस को वहां पर
ट्रिगर किया था सिंपल सा एक्सस को हम
ट्रिगर कर सकते हैं बहुत ही सिंपल सा फंडा
है एक्सस वाली चीज को भी एक्सस चीज भी
करना का जहां प आपको होस्ट सेडर मिल जा
रहा है वहां पर आप एक्सेस भी फाइंड कर
सकते हैं एज सिंपल एजट जैसे मेरे पास एक
कोई एसटीडीपी रिक्वेस्ट है यहां
पे मैं क्या करता
हूं एक एसटीडीपी रिक्वेस्ट पर चलते
हैं यह वाली राइट क्लिक सेंड टू रिपीटर
सॉरी
066 वाली है क्या
कोई 06 एफ वाली है क्या 0 ए6 ए ठीक है यह
वाली है राइट क्लिक करता हूं मैं सेंड टू
रिपीटर कर देता हूं यहां प य प रिपीटर पर
क्लिक किया मैंने गो प क्लिक किया यहां पर
हम रिस्पांस आ जाएगा गेटवे टाइम आउट आ रहा
है ठीक है कोई बात नहीं यहां पर मैं एक
काम करता
हूं
होस्ट सेडर का एक कर लेते हैं एडी होस्ट
डर होस्ट डर लब्स पर चल देते
हैं सिंपल सा तो पासवड रिसेट पॉइजनिंग
हैय इस पर चल प्रैक्टिस पे एक लैब ओपन कर
लेते हैं सिंपल सा लैब है ये लैब ओपन कर
लेते
हैं ठीक है हमने लैब ओपन कर
लिया लेट इट ओपन गाइस फिर एंड कर देंगे बस
थोड़ा सा देख लो
ये एक्सेस का पार्ट टू थोड़ी ना यार ये ह
होस्ट डर की तरह अब ये आ चुका है यहां पे
एडीपी हिस्ट्री में देख लेते हैं ओई
एडीडी हिस्ट्री में चलते
हैं यह रहा ओई एडी यह आ चुका है राइट
क्लिक करके सेंड टू रिपीटर कर देते हैं
रिपीटर प आएंगे ना गो प क्लिक करते हैं
यहां पे तो रिस्पांस में 200 होके आ रहा
है अब मान लो मैंने यहां प होस्ट को चेंज
किया यहां प मैंने bing.com कर दिया एंड
यहां पे गो प क्लिक किया गो प क्लिक किया
यहां पे और अगर ये bing.com यहां
रिफ्लेक्ट हो रही है बाय चांस यहां पे
bing.com अगर रिफ्लेक्ट हो रही है अभी
फिलहाल तो रिफ्लेक्ट नहीं हो रही है मैं
यहां पर कंट्रोल जड कर देता हूं यहां पर
एक और होस्ट डाल देता हूं
होस्ट bing.com डाल देता हूं मैं यहां पे
गो प क्लिक कर देता हूं अब यहां पे 403
फॉर बिन आ रहा है मैं यहां प एक्स फॉरवर्ड
होस्ट लगा के देख लेता हूं एक्स फॉर
वर्डेड होस्ट लगाता हूं bing.com में गो
पे क्लिक कर देता हूं यहां प 200 ओके आ
रहा है अब यहां प देख लेंगे b.com आ रहा
है कि नहीं फिलहाल तो नहीं आ रहा बट अगर
रिफ्लेक्ट हो रही है यहां पे हो रही होती
तो आप देखते हैं वहां पे कि कहां पे
रिफ्लेक्ट हो रही है उसके बाद आप एक्सेसेस
का पेलोड यहां पे डाल सकते हैं जैसे
bing.com आ गया तो मैं यहां पे एक्सएसएस
का एक पेलोड स्क्रिप्ट अ डाल दूंगा
स्क्रिप्ट
अलर्ट वन एंड स्क्रिप्ट इस तरीके से तो इस
तरीके से एक्सेसेस का पेलो डाल के आप इसको
एग्जीक्यूट करा सकते हो यहां पे गो पे
क्लिक कर सकते हो अगर ये एग्जीक्यूट हो
जाता है तो आप शो रिस्पांस इन बॉडी यहां
पे कॉपी करके एंड यहां पे आप ट्राई आउट कर
सकते हो यहां पे अगर ये एग्जीक्यूट होता
है तो एक्सस आप यहां पे आ जाएगा ठीक है
सिंपल सा फंड है ये आपका एग्जीक्यूट हो
जाएगा अगर ये इफेक्टेड होता है तो इसकी
जगह प आप चाहे तो मास एक्सेसेस अटैक भी कर
सकते हैं कैसे कर सकते हैं भैया यहां पे
bing.com इसको राइट क्लिक किया सेंड टू
इंट्रूडर कर दिया इंट्रूडर पे आ जाएंगे
यहां पे पोजीशंस प आ जाएंगे एंड यहां पे
सारे पोजीशंस यहां पे क्लियर है यहां मैं
डाल देता हूं अपना एरो कर्सर एंड यहां प
ऐड कर देता हूं
तो यहां पर मैंने ऐड कर दिया क्योंकि बंगड
कॉ के बाद डालना है पेलोड यहां पर करते
हैं य पर लोड पर क्लिक करते हैं यहां पर
एक्सस का पेलो डाल देंगे तो मैं यहां पर
एक्सस के पेलोड की कोई लिस्ट उठा लेता हूं
जैसे यह रही पेलोड के लिए इस ओपन किया य
एक् ओपन आ ग य प अब य स्टार्ट अटैक करता
हूं यहां प एंड ये अटैक स्टार्ट हो जाएगा
तो अगर कोई पेलोड एग्जीक्यूट हो रहा है
यहां प एक्स का पेलोड यहां प बेसिकली तो
यह यहां पे दिखा देगा यहां पर शो करेगा तो
लेंथ यहां पर 1157 है इससे बड़ी कोई लेंथ
है
क्या ओके कोई ऐसी कोई लेंथ नहीं है 63
वाली आ रही है यहां पे राइट क्लिक करके शो
रिस्पांस इन ब्राउजर कॉपी करके अगर ये
एक्सेसेस से इफेक्टेड होगा तो इस तरीके से
आप चेक आउट कर सकते हैं बट उसके लिए पहले
होस्टड इंजेक्शन से इफेक्टेड होना चाहिए
जो कि फिलहाल ये नहीं था इसलिए यहां पे ये
चीज नहीं आ रही है बट मैंने आपको तरीका
बता दिया किस तरीके से कर सकते हैं यहां
पे सिंपल आप bing.com या जो भी जो पहले
ओपन डायरेक्शन के लिए करते थे चेक कीजिए
अगर यहां पे रिफ्लेक्ट हो रही है वो चीज
देखिए डबल कोट डबल कोट क्लोजिंग में आपकी
हो रही है या सिंगल कोड क्लोजिंग में या
सिंपल सा क्लोजिंग में हो रहा है तो वो
देखिए और उसके अकॉर्डिंग एक्सेस का यहां
पे क्राफ्ट कीजिए और ट्र कीजिए एक्सस को
पॉप अप कराने के लिए देन आप यहां पे एक्सस
के लिए भी ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं ठीक है
आई होप आप सब समझ गए होंगे यहां पर हमारे
लिन पच इस को जरूर फॉलो कीजिएगा डिफ साइबर
सिक्योरिटी ठीक है
भैया यह जरूर से जरूर फॉलो कर लीजिएगा
ओके और अगर आपको नहीं पता गाइस तो हमारा
एक मोबाइल एप्लीकेशन भी
है जो कि डेनिक्स एडमी है जो कि आपको
तो मैं आपको वो भी दिखा देता हूं यहां
पे तो बेसिकली
मा इंस्टिट्यूट पप आता है माय इंस्टिट्यूट
ठीक है
माय
इंस्टिट्यूट यह ऐप आती है आईओएस वालों के
लिए ठीक है तो आप माय इंस्टिट्यूट पप
इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं यह वाली ये तो फिलहाल
ये ये तो प्ले स्टोर से खुल रही है बट एल
वाली पे ओपन होगी मा इंटूट इसको इंस्टॉल
कीजिएगा ऑर्ग कोड मांगेगा आपसे तो ऑर्ग
कोड जो है वो आप वो हमारा जो ऑर्ग कोड है
वो डाल सकते हैं जो हमारी अ स्पेसिफिक और
कोड है वो डाल सकते हैं ओ आरजी कोड दैट इज
बीडी आईवी एफ वाई एंड देन आप अपने नंबर से
लॉग इन करके यूज कर सकते हैं हमारे
कोर्सेस वगैरह को एप्लीकेशन को एक्सप्लोर
कर सकते हैं
दैट्ची जें अमेजिंग होती रहती है और आज के
आज के क्लास के लिए बस इतना ही ठीक है हां
थैंक यू फॉर गिविंग अमेजिंग बाउटी क्लासेस
थैंक यू वेलकम
वेलकम ओके ग्रेट ग्रेट ग्रेट ग्रेट ग्रेट
तो इसको रिपीट कीजिएगा वीडियो को जरूर आज
का थोड़ा सा
कॉम्प्लेक्शन कीजिएगा आपको ज्यादा मजा
आएगा ठीक है तो बस आज के सेशन को यहां पे
एंड करते हैं गाइ धन्यवाद जवाइन करने के
लिए ऐसे ही बना के रहिए आते रहिए तब
ज्यादा मजा आएगा आपकी जितनी ज्यादा अ